- Hey, guys, big announcement.
"Trash Taste" is officially going on tour.
- Whoo!
(clapping and cheering)
- So we can't give too
many details right now,
but we do talk about it
quite a bit in this video.
So, we just wanted to let you guys know.
There will be more information coming
at a later date, very soon.
- Anyway, guys, on with the episode.
- Did you ever have to
look into your security?
- No, 'cause no one was like
doing any nefarious shit.
- Right. Yeah.
- Well, I say that,
but somebody did mail a tub of shit
to a company address
that I was registered at.
- I shouldn't laugh,
but that's very funny.
- It was in like a
Tupperware kind of thing.
- Like here is your
tub of horse shit, sir.
- So how long did it take you guys
to realize it was horse shit?
- It was probably after my
third spoonful that I did, yeah.
(laughing)
(upbeat music)
- Top of the morning to you, laddies.
- Oh my fucken God.
- Welcome back to another episode
of "Trash Taste" podcast.
- I apologize
for any.
- Maybe I'm not ready.
(laughing)
- Apparently, we weren't ready either.
- That's how I'm starting it off.
That's how I'm starting it off.
Welcome to the "Trash Taste" podcast.
I'm Joey and I'm with
Connor and Garnt as always.
And I had to do that intro
because of this guy sitting next to me.
Introduce yourself.
- Hi, I'm the token Irishman for the day.
- Yeah, awesome.
- Yeah.
- Awesome.
- Have you ever had an Irish
person on your podcast?
- I don't believe we have.
- No, no, no.
- I mean, I don't know many
Irish people to begin with, so-
- Me, neither.
- Well, but yeah.
We got Jacksepticeye on.
- Yeah, thank you very much for coming on.
- No problem, yeah.
Yeah, pretty much.
- Why?
- How are you doing?
- That's very aggressive.
- How are you today?
- Tear me down.
- How are you?
- I'm good, okay.
- Geez. Yeah.
Woke up a little bloated,
but I'm feeling fine now.
Like what else?
Like my stool was good.
Like what else do you wanna know?
I'm good.
(laughing)
- Yeah, 'cause you were telling us earlier
that you've only done like a few podcasts
in your entire YouTube career,
which considering how long
you've been on YouTube,
absolutely is like
really surprising to me.
- I mean, no one asks.
Everyone has their podcast.
- Is that the secret?
Just ask.
- Yeah.
- I think it's 'cause they're
scared to ask, you know?
'Cause when someone's kind of like,
well known and big it's
like, if I ask, am I like,
am I overreaching?
- You're just too famous, Sean.
- Yeah, I'm very intimidating.
Whenever people see me online,
like it's too scary
and they are like what if he yells at me?
- I feel like
when you're known as being nice as well,
it's even scary actually.
Like what if that's just a monster.
- What if I'm one guy?
- What if that's where Sean is.
- One with you. (indistinct)
- Bro, if you send the
DM, they don't reply back.
You're just like you're
destroyed for the year.
Yeah.
- You're just fucked, yeah.
But I guess, I don't think there's anyone
watching this episode today
who doesn't know who you are.
- There probably is.
- But just in case there is,
just in case there's a person
who's been under a rock,
can you very briefly explain what you do?
- No.
- In a non-cynical way, if possible.
- I started off doing
gaming videos on YouTube
and it's since progressed
into mainly gaming,
but kind of everything.
- I've done a tour.
- Right.
- I have a coffee company.
I have a clothing company,
none of which I have with me,
which is very (indistinct) iPhone.
- What would've been the
best time of (indistinct)
- Yeah, just have it stick it all over me.
- Yeah, well we'll get our
editor to put it on screen,
you know? Yeah.
- And that's all good.
- Put on Joey's face. Not why.
Yeah, by that.
- I'm like the same
complexion as a coffee beans.
So just put on top.
- I didn't say that.
- But yeah.
And then you have amassed how
many fucken subscribers now?
Like 700 million, whatever it is?
- Yeah, yeah.
We'll go with that.
- It's a lot, it's a lot.
- What are you on, right now?
- That's like 28.4, I think.
- Yeah, just a casual.
- It's scroll down a lot.
- But which, I gotta ask.
Which number did you just like stop,
like looking at it and
just stop caring about it?
'Cause I think like,
I think every big YouTube I've talked to,
they read your point and then
they just forget what number
that they're at.
- Yeah.
- I think it was after 6
million I think was when,
'cause they were coming
in so quick and so often
that it was like after
six, I was like, okay,
I dunno what to do with this anymore.
- Right.
- Like a million is like
a big deal for everyone.
And then you hit five and
then like between five and 10
is a little nebulous.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- What's going on?
- [Garnt] Right.
- I didn't know why people were there
and I was just trying not
to annoy anybody to them off
or get them to go away.
So I was like, just keep my
head down and stay going.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
- None of us
are at that point.
- No, everyone can't relate.
- Can't relate.
- It's probably more
of like a time exposure
more than it is like a milestone.
I think miles.
I think subscriber
milestones are kinda easy
to judge your time on YouTube.
Before they happen, you
kind of remember them.
But I think for everybody
it's kinda like a time base,
after like a couple of years
you kind of got into it,
you know who you are and
what you're doing and yeah.
- Yeah.
So, how long have you been on YouTube?
Like when was the exact beginning
where you started your first upload?
- End of 2012.
So I'll be 10 years at
the end of this year.
- Like very end?
- Like end of November, start of December.
- You survived.
- For some reason,
I thought it was way longer than 10 years.
'Cause you seem like,
it feels like you've been
around since basically
the start of the platform,
at least from my perspective.
So hearing that it's not even 10 years
that like blows my mind actually.
- Yeah, it's really weird 'cause
I'm technically like
the second generation.
'Cause you have "Smash and Tobskas",
all those generations, first gen.
- Right.
- And then,
for the longest time,
I wasn't even considered the
second wave that people said
that I was like adding
into the tail end of that.
And then now a certain
amount of time has gone by
and everyone's convinced I've
been since the beginning.
So I don't know when that happened, but...
- Do people still use the
whole generation thing,
even for like near YouTubers now?
Or is it just talking about more of...
- Yeah, like what generation
are we in writing?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I have no idea.
It's like 12 generation YouTuber.
- I think people just know
the cycles when they come in,
but no one has a generation anymore.
- Yeah, I mean like, 'cause I remember it.
I think it was much easier to
define generations back then
because one, people gave a shit
about things like YouTube rewind.
So it was, it was,
it was much easier to like
segregate to like, okay,
I recognize these faces.
Oh there's a new,
there's a lot of new
faces to YouTube rewind.
- Yeah, that's true.
- And then suddenly you're just like,
I do not know anyone in this video.
- I think it's also because during
the first couple of generations,
there was like a literal handful of people
that were the ones that made it, right.
- Yeah.
- But now it's like
how many people would you consider
the ones made it, you know.
- There's a lot of channels now
that have like 50 plus million subscribers
that you wouldn't.
- Yeah.
It just never happens.
- I did like a higher or lower thing
where you like guess YouTube subs.
It's like a new updated version
of it with current stats.
- Right.
- And I went through it and
it was this person versus
this person, I was like, well they,
I think they're Spanish YouTubers.
I was like, they're gonna
have a lot, obviously.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- I was like,
I have no idea who this person is.
And it was like 40
versus 50 million drive.
I'd never heard of any of them.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's crazy.
'Cause the rewinds went
international then as well
and started involving
like Japanese people and.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I forgot about that, yeah.
- From Wilder.
- Yeah, assuming you've
been in YouTube Rewind then?
- Yeah, I think I've been in two,
but I've never been there in person.
- Right.
- Because every time
they ask me, I either
had something going on
or they asked me to do some
stupid where it was like,
you get on a green screen
and like pretend you're
falling through space.
'Cause I was the year
like the Katy Perry meme.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I was like I'm not doing that.
I was like, I just won't be in it this.
(laughing)
- Yeah.
- You cannot pay me
any amount to do that.
- Yeah.
It felt like everyone was
in it for clout to be like,
that's me everyone, I'm in it.
- Yeah.
I don't need that.
Because if you are in it,
you're probably in it for like 1 second.
- Yeah.
- At the most, right.
- If I'm in it, I wanna be
in it for something cool
or good or like you or (indistinct)
I was like I don't wanna be ...
Everyone thinks I'm cringey already.
I don't wanna be in it for like
wacky on a fucken green tree.
- Well back then, they did.
- Oh, okay.
- Oh, okay, okay.
- Wait, what year was that?
Like...
- I think it was like 2016 or 17.
- Oh, okay.
- Like green hair era.
- Right.
Oh, okay, okay.
- So it was like the peak of
when I was like a caricature
of myself and then everyone expected
like a certain thing and...
- Well, actually that's
an interesting question.
Would you say at the
beginning of your career,
you very much were like
a caricature of yourself
and that you've kind of
like changed your image
as you've like evolved in
your career here on YouTube.
- I think at the beginning
I was like someone else completely
'cause I started off and
I wasn't like being Irish
or like being myself.
So I was like, I'll speak clearly.
And that was like, hello everybody.
This is me.
(laughing)
- For some reason it
just sounded American.
I guess that's what they thought.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(indistinct)
- I did the same thing whenever
I try to make an accent.
Just sounds like Mark Thought.
- Well, you have the tone.
- Right, right.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But I think I was that for a while.
And then I was like no one's
watching, no one cares.
I was leaning into myself,
into my culture a bit more,
- Yeah.
- Separate myself out.
And that was where top of the morning
and everything started.
- Yeah.
- And then I think after
four or five years,
then it was like peak caricature,
'cause then you're just,
you know what people like,
you know what they wanna hear.
- Yeah.
- Like you guys will mention
an anime or something,
at some point in this episode, I imagine.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You go through the numbers.
You clearly haven't watched
the many episodes of track.
- Talk about that.
- You kinda just know
what your audience wanted
after a while and you run
into that more and more.
- So is that like kind of
what inspired the whole,
I guess screaming at the top of your face,
like type of caricature, right?
- It was like happy
wheels, like two a week.
And it was like, you
know what people want,
they love the catch phrases.
- Right, right.
- Right.
- It's kinda like ticking boxes.
And then you kinda get tired of that
and move on something else.
- Well, I feel like that was
an entire generation of YouTube
where like, especially like
the first wave of let's players,
it was very much about a
gimmick and high energy.
It needed to be like high energy, right?
If you are speaking below the
decibels of a live concert,
then you are just not
on making on YouTube.
And that's what.
- If you feel mic was not peaking,
you weren't doing it right.
- Yeah.
- So people still
purposefully peak their mic
just to make it sound louder.
- Right.
- Yeah, right.
- Right, they do?
- Yeah.
I was like, have you
ever watched like a well.
- 'Cause it's like a,
like a deep fried meme
where it sounds funny.
It's like the louder you shout,
the cooler it sounds.
I keep, oh God, every time I
tune into like Tommy and it's.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Tommy, I love you.
You're great.
You're super funny, but
fix your fucken microphone.
- I think it's for like
the Tyler One kind of mic.
- Let's forgive him instead
of him being a moron.
(laughs)
- Well, we're not friends
with him like this.
- Yeah.
He just turned 18, he's
not a child anymore.
- So you can literally bully him.
- Beat the shit out of him, you know.
- You'd be one felon.
- And you can go to jail now.
- My God.
- So mentioning anime,
you are a big anime guy?
(laughing)
- I want to be.
I wanna have like that knowledge
of like the obscure ship,
but I'm such a normy
when it comes to anime.
- But most conversational
you'll ever have about anime
is a normy conversation.
- That's true.
- Just really got
to know so many things
and you, they never,
you just seem pretentious if
you're like, I know this show.
- No, no, no.
- True. You do.
- You guys do seem pretentious.
- Okay. Like absolutely.
We have all this knowledge
and then we have the same conversations,
90% of the time anyway,
because everyone's watching.
- That's what I've learned
recently though, is that like,
it doesn't matter how much
actual knowledge you have
on the medium because 90% of
the questions are gonna be,
so what did you think about
the latest "Attach on Titan"s?
Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- It's gonna get to
like that level, right?
- Yeah.
- Look, that new season of
"Attach on Titan" sucks.
I hate it.
- I think it was really,
I think building up for the last one.
- Well, yeah.
I'm being a bit harsh, but
I just, I feel like Connor,
we actually have it.
- Was like, yeah.
Okay, we're getting into this now.
- I loved all the first three
seasons I got into the manga.
I read all of it.
The ending was like, whatever was...
- Oh, I haven't read it yet.
I haven't read the manga yet.
- So you are even like
ahead of us in this game.
- Yeah, yeah. At the ending
I was like, yeah, whatever.
And then I was like
waiting for it to happen.
I was like, there's a couple
of good scenes in there.
And then it happened.
I was like, manga are so
much better than that.
Like I feel like JuJutsu Kaisen came out
at the same time
and it's like, that's what you can do.
And this is what we're getting.
- Actually sound like an anime fan.
- Yeah.
Yes.
- This is this.
- You're naming studio.
- I like that.
- You know what, like the
base level of mapper is,
is like more than most people.
- Now I'm just pissing off your audience.
- Most of them don't come here
for anime, but they're like,
my God, they're gonna speak about it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Because I didn't expect
that you would just name-drop
an anime studio.
'Cause that's like,
even you call yourself a casual anime fan,
but that level of knowledge
is even more than most people I talk to.
You know?
So you like JuJutsu Kaisen as well then?
- Yeah, I fucken love Jujutsu Kaisen
- Wow, not like him.
- Okay.
Jujutsu Kaisen story is like whatever.
It's so like by the boat, it's so plain,
but I feel like it leans into that.
And I was like,
you're just here to watch cool animation.
You're just here to watch cool fights.
- Yes, yes.
- It's like-
- I love this show so much.
- It's like "Naruto" again, but it's like,
we cut out all the
annoying shit and just...
it's like, here's just fight
scenes, like go for it,
no one cares.
- Yeah, yeah.
Also "Naruto" doesn't have like Toto.
So like-
- That's true.
He's like the best character.
- But it does have Kakashi,
which is just basically Gojo,
just like all over again, you know?
Yeah.
- But Gojo is more marketable. Right?
Gojo is really.
- Younger, he's sexier, he's new.
- The youngest sexier Kakashi.
- I mean.
- But I did watch "Naruto"
for the first time,
like last year.
- Yeah, yeah, I remember you telling me.
- Like, wait you watched,
oh, how did that happen?
You watched narrative for
the first time in 2021.
- Well, I did too.
- Yeah, 'cause I remember you
texting me about it actually.
- Yeah.
- You are like,
do you think I should?
And I was like, I mean, you go for it.
Like yeah.
- Cause my girlfriend
had watched it growing up
and that's got her into stuff
and she lived in Japan
actually for a long time.
- Oh really?
- Did a Masters in Japanese
and everything.
- Oh, she did.
- Oh.
- Okay.
That stuff was what got her into it.
- Right, right.
- Right.
- Then since I don't have any
nostalgia for, it was like,
let's watch it now and see if it holds up.
And we kind of did that.
- Get a non-bias view on it.
- Yeah, we did like the
non-filler sort of stuff.
Like people had listed
on like Reddit, what?
Like the key ones to watch.
- Yeah, there's websites dedicated.
- Filler.
- They basically cut out
like a third of non
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
- So we did that and I was
like, it's still way too long.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I was like, we need a
"Naruto Kai" to come out with
or a brotherhood or something.
- Right, right.
Yeah, because like,
I'm curious since you've
watched "Naruto" last year,
I've always thought that it's
like, if you read the manga,
maybe it would be a
much better experience.
But I think with the way
anime production was back then
with a lot of filler,
not just in episodes,
but within certain scenes,
it would just have dragged so much.
Did you think it's a good show?
- I think it is.
I think it has a lot of heart to it.
And I think knowing the
pedigree that it has
and the fact that it
started all of those trends,
that and Dragonball kind of
like pioneered a lot of that,
like long drawn out battle kind of shit.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And the fact that, that's why I'm saying
like Jujutsu Kaisen feels
like that, but modernized.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, like cut out
a lot of the nonsense.
But at the same time they cut out most of-
- I love about Jack
has more of a in-depth-
- This is amazing.
- Opinion of JuJutsu Kaisen
compared to like most people.
- I agree though, JuJutsu
Kaisen is just like,
we're getting on with it,
shit happening always
like the first episode,
like they just get right into it.
Whereas like, you know,
you can tell shows from like two thousands
when they take their sweet fucken time
to let anything happen initially.
- Oh, like "Demon Slayer".
- ""Demon Slayer"" takes long.
- ""Demon Slayer"" is like "Naruto",
but the exact same where it's like
all the annoying characters,
all the fillership,
all of the like drawn out battles.
- Right, right.
- The animation's so good.
Just do that over and over again.
- Was there any animes you
watched that you were like,
I'll give it a shot and you
were like very surprised
that you enjoyed it?
- "Fullmetal Alchemist".
- I love that show.
- Yeah, same, same.
- He hasn't-
- I love "Fullmetal Alchemist".
It's amazing.
- Who's your favorite character?
- It's Ed, you know,
everyone loves Ed.
- He's right's, that's all the truth.
- That was one I had heard
a lot of brotherhood.
- Brotherhoodhood is (indistinct)
- And then I watched it and I was like,
and then it became my
favorite of all time.
Oh. Because I was like, it's just lean.
It has a story to tell,
it gets in, gets out.
Does it?
- Yeah, I mean like,
I think like for the anime
community, "Fullmetal Alchemist"
is kind of like the
godfather of like anime,
you know what I mean?
Where it's just like on the top
of like every top anime list
of all time.
It's like sacri, if you don't watch.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's just on the top.
- It's just always on the top.
And of course everyone looks there
and they're just like, yeah you know.
It's probably the top, you know,
I'm not gonna argue that
"Fullmetal Alchemist",
I haven't even seen it.
And I'm just like, yeah, it's
probably the top, you know.
- Of course, that was why I watched it.
'Cause it was on the top of
everyone's list and I was like,
sure, I'll give it a shot.
And I was like, that makes sense.
- It feels really unremarkable
when you start watching it.
But something about it
just keeps you so engaged
and I dunno what quite it is.
- Yeah.
Actually I think it's
just like a really just.
- Put it on now we can watch it today.
- Live reaction.
- Right.
My fans have been trying to
get me to watch for like five,
six years now, but like yeah.
Ask someone, actually asking
you guys anime question
as someone who hasn't seen
"Fullmetal Alchemist",
you know, you have shows
like "Attach on Titan",
like Jujutsu Kaisen and like
"Demon Slayer", which you know,
is very much critically acclaimed,
but there's always, like,
there always seems to
be a group that is anti,
like tries to bring it down.
Like the "Attach on Titan" is
mid crew or the JuJutsu Kaisen
is mid crew, whatever.
But like, it just doesn't
seem like that exists
for "Fullmetal Alchemist".
And I was just like, why?
- Maybe it's because...
Well, I mean, for one,
it's like a genuinely good show for one,
but I think it's also the fact that now
it's just put on such a
legendary status that it's like,
I don't know there isn't...
I think it's just a losing battle.
- Yeah.
- If you go out there and try
to be that guy to be like,
oh, I think it's fucken
overrated or whatever.
Then everyone I think
collectively is like, okay,
sit down, you know.
Kind of, alright baby.
- Boy, it's just, it's very lean.
Like it has like 65 episodes or something,
which nowadays is like unheard of.
- Yeah.
- It's just, I think
because Brotherhood came out,
it did a lot of the heavy lifting
'cause the original one was
kind of all over the place.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It had that filler stuff.
And everyone's like, no one cares.
So now just like,
here's like a decent
story starting to finish.
It keeps like having twist and
twist and twist and the pace.
is broken, so...
- Yeah, I think it was just like, yeah,
just a well oiled machine
that just, was good enough.
- What an interesting way to describe it.
- It was, it was like a-
- Well oiled machine.
- It was a well oil machine
that just like-
- It was lubed up.
- It was lubed the fuck
up. It was really smooth.
It worked perfectly like
everything it tried to do,
It did well.
- Yeah.
Those are pretty mature for that era.
I think.
- Yeah, there's still a
lot of like up scenes,
like even in today's standards, I think.
- And I think.
- Even like in the mainstream,
I think "Attach on Titan" is
the only thing really sense
that's like people are fucken
dying left, right and center.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, I think like "Attach on Titan"
is 'cause most time when an
anime gets super, super popular,
it's basically just shown
in jump it's, you know,
shows like JuJutsu Kaisen,
"Demon Slayer", My Hero Academia,
then "Attach on Titan" has
been like the adult show.
I guess the most adult show that's gotten
as close to mainstream as
I think anime has gotten.
- Even though it's still
technically a shown in Barnyard.
- Yeah, it is technically.
- You know, even though
it technically is published and
shown in magazine, you know,
it's seen as like more
mature, especially, you know,
you watch "Attach on
Titan" and you're like
this ain't no My Hero Academia, you know?
- No, no, no, definitely not.
- Do you have like a
favorite anime or manga then.
- Favorite anime is "Fullmetal".
It used to be, well,
it was like the first
season of One Punch Man.
I really loved as well.
- Okay, okay, classic.
- And the second season
was like a step down
and I was like ah, man, you
could have just left it there,
wouldn't fucken kill.
- Yeah, I think I know what
your favorite manga is.
- It's?
- It's "Berserk", right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- You've read "Berserk"?
I feel like anyone who's read "Berserk"-
- Oh my God.
- Yeah, yeah.
It's like top of their list.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I think it's my favorite, too.
- Yeah.
'Cause I started and
again, like Full Metal
It was like top of everyone's list.
And I was like Dark Souls,
like from soft or huge into them.
I was like, I'll give it a shot.
And then I had the Dark Horse,
like the conditions.
- The thick ones, the
thick ones, right, yeah.
- Like one of those for a long time.
And I was like, pandemic's happening?
I'll finally read it
and then just blast through
the whole thing, right?
- Yeah.
It's the same.
I did it just pandemic
as well and fuck man.
I don't know.
- It's unreal.
- You can't put it down.
- Anyone who's like, hasn't read it
and hears us talk like that,
it's like it's worth it.
It's really drawn out, but
it's like the only thing
that actually benefits from it, I think.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- Yeah-
- I'll go on.
No, I feel like the pacing
is perfect for the story
it wants to tell.
It's not always like an action fest,
but I feel like even
like the quieter moments,
just draw you in and immerse you so much.
- I think for me,
the quieter moments of "Berserk"
is what I enjoyed the most.
- Oh, they hit really hard.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Because there are some panels
that are just like so still.
And yet it's like, I don't know,
very intense at the same time.
It's very difficult to explain, but like-
- Just like the scale of
it, 'cause it sets up,
it's like, okay, here's one bad guy.
And then follows that
the entire way through.
They're not like here's
an ark with that bad guy
and then tell someone else.
And then you're like reeling
through it being like, okay,
when do we get back to good shit again?
- Yeah.
- It's like one, one pillar
the entire way through.
And then the hero is like,
it doesn't do that stuff.
Or like his power level goes down
and then it goes back up and down.
It's like, it's just very
consistent the whole way through.
And it's more about
the interpersonal drama
more than anything.
- Yeah, I knew it was special
'cause when you get like one
third of the way through,
something and you're like, oh no, yeah.
Oh no, I'm getting through this.
- Yeah.
- It's gonna end.
I'm gonna have to say.
- But you guys at the golden
age and it's like, wait,
this isn't a flashback.
(laughing)
- This is the whole thing.
And he like, that's the prologue,
that's the prologue to this story.
- God.
- But yeah, I was ashamed of that.
We're never gonna see the end
of it. I still haven't like,
I've still not brought up the courage
to read the final like few chapters, yet.
- I still haven't read the final volume.
It's just been like sitting on my shelf.
- I'm not bigger read than you guys.
- I've got, I've read it.
- I bought it on release.
I got like the special
soundtrack edition to it as well.
And I don't wanna read it
'cause I know once I read that, that's it.
- There's no more "Berserk".
There's no more "Berserk".
- I totally agree.
- Have they said definitively
if it's done now or not?
- So for a little while,
there was this rumor
that was going around where
Hakusensha, the publishers
were thinking about
continuing on the series
and then it got a ton of backlash online.
- Yeah.
- Just being like, no dude,
just let it go to rest.
So right now, we don't know yet.
There is a possibility that they might.
I personally don't want
that because again,
like I haven't read the
last couple of chapters,
but I heard that like the
last couple of chapters
actually kind of has like a
somewhat round ending to it.
- Right.
Or I guess.
- It feels like you're getting
very close to the end almost.
- Yeah, in a weird way.
- You can kind of predict
what you think will happen.
- Yeah.
There's yeah.
- And I don't feel like, you know,
obviously Miura is like
one of the, arguably,
the greatest mangaka who's ever lived.
- Yeah.
- You know, especially
with his masterpiece, "Berserk"
and just who would even one,
who would even want to try
to even take up that mantle.
Yeah, like I wouldn't
want to be that person.
And two, it kind of just
feels to me at least,
it kind of feels disrespectful
if someone passes away and you know,
there are some instances
that maybe, you know,
some people can continue on that vision
if they know what's going to happen.
But in this case, it just feels
like such a personal story
that I don't really feel
like anyone can tell that,
but Miura himself.
- Yeah.
- Maybe we'll get like a thing
of like his notes or like-
- Yeah, yeah.
- Hard book of what he
was thinking would happen.
I feel like that's the best way
'cause then people can just
make up their own ending up.
- Whatever, fill in the blanks, right.
- I should never be
disappointed by an ending
that doesn't happen.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Sure, sure.
- I saw something similar to that
when I went to the
"Berserk" exhibit though.
It was like I was trying to
rub it in now. (laughing)
- He's like, let me flex on you right now.
- Let me flex on you, great.
There was like a kind of a glass cabin
of like a bunch of like Miura's notes
that were kind of written down.
And there was like, not
nothing really like concrete
that went after the manga or
after where the manga ended.
But it was just really cool to see like,
I guess it's like thought
process and like sketches
on like a bunch of
sheet because it's like,
it's like really just super fine stuff.
Like very, very basic
shapes for characters
who then ended up being
characters like Zog or like yeah.
You know, these like insane
pieces of art essentially
in longer form.
- Right.
- Yeah.
What was I going on about?
- Yeah. I went to the "Berserk" Museum.
- Professional podcaster.
(laughing)
- That wasn't even like
a question was just-
- Take his phone and go through pictures
and you're like (indistinct)
- You'll never see it.
(laughing)
- Yeah, so did you have a point, Joey
or did you just want rub it into us?
- Yeah.
I just wanted some
flags, that's all, yeah.
It was a great example.
- I gotta drink my tea here.
- Have you ever been to Japan yourself?
- Once, yeah.
We, oh God, what year was it?
It was before, it was like 2019, I think.
- Right.
- Right before the pandemic?
- Yeah.
We went 'cause I got offered
to go to a thing with 'cause Godzilla
was coming out and Detective
Pikachu were coming.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Oh, that's right.
- The second Godzilla movie.
So we got to go with Warner Brothers,
flew us out to do a thing.
- Oh wow.
- Right.
- And then 'cause my
girlfriend lived there
and she's fluent and everything.
It was like, can we like extend our trip?
So we went for 10 days.
- [Garnt] Oh, nice, nice.
- And was it four on our own?
And then the rest was like
doing stuff that it was.
- It was awesome.
- Yeah. Did it feel like it
was enough days or you like,
oh no, I need more.
- I think for that trip, it was
'cause we ended with all
the like press junky.
- Okay, okay, okay.
- So it felt like we, we like
revisited the same place.
We went to like Howard Juku the first time
when we were there
and then got to see like
the temples and stuff.
And then when we went back it
was like, here you go again.
But it's like scheduled out.
So it was a little different,
but we got to go to the Toho place
and we gotta see like all
the original like props
for all the earlier movies and stuff.
- Oh, that's so cool.
- Right, right.
- Like the original costume
and everything was there.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That stuff was really cool.
Got to see Ryan Reynolds again.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
- He waved at me.
- You in Free Guy.
- He waved at you.
- Well, that was the thing.
I met him for the Deadpool thing.
And then the Detective Pikachu thing,
he was on a boat and he
was like, hey, that guy.
And he like waved down at me.
I was like, holy fuck.
(laughing)
- He remembers.
- He remembered me.
And then we like took
a picture all together
and I was like standing
next to him being like.
(sniffles)
(laughing)
- Cool.
- Yeah, good to see you.
(laughing)
- I will remember this smell.
- So there was a lot
of things in that trip
that like made it a much bigger deal.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Well how did like the Free Guy
and like the Deadpool collab come about?
And what was it like, you know,
being in projects like that?
- Absolute fluke.
- Right.
- When the Deadpool was
coming out, the second one
and then I loved the first one already,
and I was such a massive
fan of Ryan anyway.
- Yeah.
- And then I was talking
about him so much in my videos
and just kind of like
annoyingly, I would say.
I feel like if someone did that about me,
I'd be like fucken weirdo.
- Yeah.
- But I had been talking about him so much
that he liked one of my tweets one day.
'Cause I guess people were
just badgering him about me.
And then I was coming
back from a trip one time
and then saw my phone
that he had followed me.
And I was like, oh fuck. It
was like dad found my account.
- Oh no.
(laughing)
Delete everything.
But then I think that happened.
And then I had played the Deadpool game
just 'cause for search engine,
the movie was coming out.
- Played, people were watching.
And then I think Warner Brothers,
whoever were over it at
the time got wind of that
and then got in contact
with me and were like,
well now we have to put
you in a room together
'cause you guys have interacted.
You've played the game and yeah.
Then 'cause of that, it
like snowballed from there
to like all the other
celebrity (indistinct)
- Wow.
Wow.
- It was just random chance.
It was a pure miracle.
- That's so cool.
- Basically, just meme up your
favorite celebrity, right.
- And then just be the biggest
fanboy online, make it-
- It's like the worst story ever.
- Just keep tweeting at them.
- Just make as much noise as possible
to your favorite celebrity,
and then eventually they'll notice you.
- Annoy the out of them. (laughing)
- Yeah, that was so cool though.
- You were also in a, what was it?
Poppy play time, the newest one recently.
- Oh yeah.
- That was...
I played the game and
I was like, is that...
'cause it's not like the
grimmiest I'm like, is that.
- Yeah, and you just see like my chin
and then once my full face comes in,
everyone has the same reaction.
- Yeah, yeah.
What was that all about?
I mean...
- Again, in the first chapter I was like,
I could do a voice in this game,
put me in the game and
then they messaged me
after being like, do you
wanna be in the game?
- I was like, is that easy?
- Yeah.
I just fucken annoyed people.
(laughing)
But I'd been in a couple of things
like Bendi and the Ink
Machine and Puppet Combo
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah.
- So I think they were
just like, yeah, be in it.
But I didn't think I'd be a person in it.
They were like...
It was just tapes of
voices the first time.
And I was like, I can do that.
- You thought it was just
gonna be a voice of you.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Right.
- And then they sent me the
thing and was like dress up
in like a yellow shirt
and like have a lanyard,
which they didn't give a
template for and I had to make.
- Right.
- And then I was just
like, okay, I'll act.
And I was like fuck, now I
have to like learn the lines,
like be in a camera and like right.
Stuck me.
So like 17 just to get like a sentence of-
- This feels like big brain though.
Instead of having to
play the game yourself,
just be in every other lens.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It works out great.
Then I play it and I'm
like, I'm in, Poppy.
Play time.
Use of a thumbnail of you.
- How is it like having to like memorize
a script versus just, you know,
doing a let's play on just
being a YouTuber, I guess,
because I feel like there must be
so much more pressure because-
- Yeah. Do you have like
an acting background?
Any were you just winging it?
- Not at all.
- [Garnt] Yeah, just wing it.
- Well, I'm a huge fan
of just watching movies
and I love acting in general
and I always thought I
would do it eventually.
- Yeah.
- And I have like mini
characters on my own channel
where I like play them every now and then.
- And yeah.
- When I do something
with those in the future
and that was like a sandbox for me
to just play around in it though.
And be like, if I can do
it, I'll figure it out.
But these things was like,
just here's a role if you wanna do it.
- Yeah.
- Right, right.
- Right.
- Audition for them
here and there.
And I don't know, it's weird.
It's a fun challenge though, I think.
- Yeah, definitely, definitely.
- Yeah, 'cause I guess you
just kind of like in Free Guy,
least it was kind of like a cameo.
So you got kind of just got like
to play yourself, I guess, right?
- Yeah, it was really bizarre
'cause when they sent me
the thing being like,
if you wanna be in Free
Guy and I was like,
it's a movie with Ryan
Reynolds, why wouldn't I be?
I was like, I'll do literally anything.
- To be my boy Ryan, my boy
we're friends by the way.
- He waved at me once, so
we're basically friends.
- You open up your Ryan Reynolds shrine
and you're just like...
- Just like you flex "Berserk" on me.
I'll flex Ryan Reynolds on you.
(laughing)
- That's definitely
a bigger flex.
- He texts me a video for
my birthday this year.
- Oh, shit.
- Oh, no way.
Saying like happy birthday and like.
- That's like a $700 old cameo, right?
- Yeah.
Just got your name wrong like...
- It's good to see you John,
but yeah, for Free Guy,
I got like a script of like,
there's like a bunny
rabbit character in it
when they go into the world.
- Right.
And it was like those lines
and I was like, oh shit,
That's like a character.
And I thought it was like,
oh just walk in the
background or something.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Sean Levy, the director
I had a call with
and I was like here learning these lines.
And I was like, okay, treat
this as an audition, okay.
And I was like shit and bricks.
I'm even getting nervous
now thinking about it.
- Right.
- And it was so scary.
And then I got on the phone with him
and he's the most infectiously
happy guy of all time.
He was like, yeah, we have this
movie and we're gonna do it,
and we'd love to have you in it.
And it's so cool, like
you'd play yourself.
And I was like, oh, this is,
I don't have to do anything,
then, it's just me.
(laughing)
- Did I get the part for myself?
- Do you want me to like...
- Read?
- Should I do a British accent?
- Or so did I get the audition?
How do I stack up against the
other Jacksepticeye auditions?
- Honestly, I would lose that audition.
I have no idea how to be myself.
But he like texts me the
lines, like a script, right.
- For an SMS.
And I was like, oh, we're
just shooting from the hip.
- Wow.
And I got to sit in my
room like with my camera
and do it as like,
they were like have it to us
by like Monday or whatever.
But I was allowed to do it on my own
with no direction and right.
They came back and they were like,
that was incredible.
We want you to in it
more here's more lines.
- Oh, really.
- If you watch the movie,
it was like,
the very starting part was
the only part I had initially.
- Right.
- I kept showing up again and again,
because they were like, you were so good.
Let's put you on again.
- And I was like, great.
- And then they were like, yeah.
Ninja was like in it.
And he sent us like a
C-920 Logitech webcam.
- And I was like Ninja, come on.
So then his part in the
movie has like a motion rig
and like a really big camera.
And I was like, no, mine
looks like shit. (laughing)
Well, it was super fun.
Really, really cool
experience to be part of.
I got people like as of like two days ago,
my chiropractor messaged me
being like I saw Free Guy.
It was incredible, I
didn't know you were in it.
I was like, yeah.
- Yeah, that is an awesome flex.
- This episode of "Trash Taste"
is sponsored by PC specialists.
- [Connor] PC specialists are one
of the leading custom PC
manufacturers in Europe,
specializing in gaming, PCs,
laptops, workstations, and more.
They have a focus on building
high performance systems
for gamers-
- Gamers?
- That's me.
- Enthusiasts.
- That's him.
- Enthusiast.
- That's me.
- Content creators.
- That's you.
- That's us.
- And professionals.
- That's not us.
- That's none of us.
- [Joey] Their easy to use
configurator allows you
to customize each component
of your build to your desire.
And each PC is meticulously
cable-managed to ensure neatness
and tested to ensure
stability and performance
unlike the boys' PCs.
- How dare you.
- All of their PCs are
powered by Windows 11.
Play time.
- Anytime.
- So if you want a new gamer PC,
then click the link in the description
and use code TRASH at the checkout.
- Back to the episode.
- I guess you talked about before,
how you felt like you played
like a caricature, you know.
At which point did you
start to like kind of,
maybe like not get tired of it,
but maybe think like you should just try
to be by yourself more.
Was there like an exact
moment or realization?
- That happens?
Yeah, it was like, I think
it was a couple of moments.
I think at the end of 2017,
I have like a video on my channel saying
it was like the worst year of my life.
And I was just miserable.
I was in like a really
crappy place mentally.
- Yeah.
- It was like the first time I ever got
to like the end of the year
and I spent Christmas alone
and I was like,
my mind went to some very dark places,
which I won't get into detail of.
- Right.
- But I was like that's not me.
I don't normally think like this,
like clearly something's wrong.
And I started like going to therapy
and I started trying to
like figure myself out
and my priorities.
And then I think like the
next two years after that,
we're still trying to
like figure shit out.
- Yeah.
- I dunno what I wanna do.
Do I do daily uploads again?
Do I work on bigger things
and then kinda getting
sick of myself and yeah.
I kept taking breaks so
periodically and going away for like
a month or two months and
trying to figure stuff out.
And then I think last year
after my dad had passed,
I was like, okay, I'm quitting.
I'm done, I'm fuckin' out.
I hate this.
- Yeah.
- I hate where the culture
of YouTube is going.
I hate everything that's going on.
I don't wanna play into the games of it.
- Yeah.
- And I was like,
I just took some time
away and I was like, well,
I don't have to take it that seriously.
I started off doing it,
like kind of in my bedroom
having fun and yeah,
just uploading daily
games and like subscribers
don't really matter that much
if you're having fun with it
and things are sustainable and
views don't matter that much
as long as you're still making,
like you're living out of it.
- Yeah.
- I've been so successful with it so far
that I'll just have fun with it again.
And I think, all of those
pieces is kind of culminated
and I was like, it's fun to do.
- Yeah, I mean, I think
since we've all done YouTube
for like quite a long time,
we forget sometimes that
YouTube is a fun job,
because there's a lot
of times when the grind
can feel endless and
you can forget sometimes
that you started it
because it's fun and it
is a genuinely fun job.
And I fee bad like saying this
'cause I'm sure a lot of people
would like obviously like
kill to be in this position.
But a lot of times when
you hear YouTubers talk
about their job, it's always
in like a negative connotation.
- Yeah, 'cause it's, well,
it becomes a thing that when
you do it to a certain level
and you get sustainable
and you start earning money
off of it and you get, yeah.
You get to a point where like
your financial side of things
are kind of in check and you're fine.
And you can afford rent
and food, which is,
most people struggle in
the friction in their life.
And then we make our own hours,
all you're left with are
like emotional problems
that you kind of have to deal
with and figure those out.
And then you have to
figure out your own brain.
And then I think for a lot of people,
it's easy to blame YouTube
for like things going wrong in your life.
If algorithms shift and
things kind of go wrong.
- Yeah.
- Or if an upload does bad,
it's like, ah, fuck the system.
And it's like maybe the
video wasn't that good.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
People are very quick
to blame the algorithm.
- Yeah, which there is a factor too.
Of course, it's not all perfect.
- Yeah. But I think, you know,
putting all your problems
on the algorithm is
something entirely different.
- It's like an easy out sometimes.
- Yeah.
- I mean, I've done it
too, I still kind of do.
- I think we all have that.
I think that's like a path
that every YouTuber does
definitely go through
at one point in their careers.
It's just a matter of like,
whether you can realize
that that is not the
entire truth, you know?
- Yeah, 'cause you put your
entire self worth into that
and when it's successful,
it's like I'm amazing.
I'm doing great.
But if that dips, then it's
like, I'm a piece of shit.
(laughing)
- I dunno how this works anymore.
That person uploaded and it's fine.
And I do the same thing.
- Yeah, and then like someone new comes on
and gets like a fucken 50
million views doing like some,
something that you think is
so simple or something you're
like, why is the algorithm
favoring this video?
And you just like, feel
like a lost soul sometimes.
- I can't imagine that daily uploads
make it easy to have time
to think about yourself and
where you are right now.
I've never done daily uploads,
but that sounds terrifying.
- I think it sucks.
I barely already have enough time
to consider my own mental health.
I feel like adding in the daily uploads,
like where do you, how was that like?
- Yeah, 'cause how long did
you do daily uploads for.
- That was like five and a half years.
- Oh my.
- It was, it was double daily.
- Did you just have like no
social life during that point?
- No.
- Okay.
I was editing everything myself.
I would wake up, get a
video ready for that day
or the two videos ready for
that day, then record two more,
edit them that night and then go to bed.
- And it was that
for five years.
- Oh my God.
- I don't do that.
It's great when everything's like firing
and like you're getting into it.
There is a passion there, like sure.
Work hard when it's there
and everything's booming,
but take some time for yourself.
- Yeah.
So did you take any breaks at all?
- Nope!
- Oh, seriously.
- I think it was like seven years
before I took my first
proper like time off.
- Oh my God.
- And that was circumstantial
for being on tour
'cause I was like, I can't upload.
I can't keep.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I tried vlogging on tour and then I was,
wasn't doing my tour properly
and it was just too much,
but that was like the
first time I was like, oh,
people will still be there if I come back.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause I feel like there is definitely
when you set yourself a schedule
and that's how you get
like a lot of success
and a lot of traffic initially.
You think that you need to stick
to this upload schedule
or this like expectations
that you've set for the viewership.
And I think one thing I will say
is I think YouTube's a lot become
a lot more lenient at least recently.
- Yeah.
- With just like realizing
that your audience
is what really holds the power.
And even if you go to like a
second channel, they will like,
your audience will follow you, you know.
- Yeah, I definitely think
like nowadays, like, you know,
like when you were starting off,
especially I think the
general consensus was like,
if you're not uploading daily,
then you're not even
in the game, you know?
Whereas like now I think
the knowledge of that not
necessarily being true
and that as Gar was saying, like,
your audience will be there
even if you change stuff around
or you move stuff around.
I think now it's just become
more like commonplace,
I think where it's like, you know,
now you have channels
that are starting off,
who aren't as pressured
to do daily uploads
if they don't want to, right.
Like there are lots of
successful channels now
that probably upload late once a month.
- Yeah.
- As long as the video's good.
- I just think the general level expected
of the videos has just gotten crazy.
- But that's the thing with daily as well
is like the daily videos weren't good.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You can't really.
- It was just like chopping
out bits and then that's it,
there was no like heavy editing on them.
- No, cause you can't do it.
Like it's physically impossible
to find the time to do that, right,
unless you're planning, you
know, weeks ahead, but...
- And there were so much shorter as well.
Like these days...
- 20 minutes, right?
- Yeah, even it was like
10, 15 minutes sometimes.
- Right.
- A lot more manageable.
- Yeah.
Like eight minutes was like the
golden zone back in the day.
Right.
- That's just so weird playing a game
for like 10 minutes then me like all guys
calling it a day here.
- I mean, that was like
early Felix was like,
amnesia was like 10 minute episodes
was like tune in tomorrow
for the next part.
- Yeah.
- It'll take you like a whole month
just to get through
like a chunk of a game.
- Yeah.
'Cause I remember early game
grams was like that as well
where it was like 10 minutes
an episode and it was like,
all I see tomorrow.
- Yeah.
- That was normal.
But now it's like unthinkable.
- Everyone's wants like
three hour videos now.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Well it's all, it's all like idea first.
- And then content after
for most of like the most
successful stuff in the platform.
- The platform, like in that time,
did you have like a basic work schedule?
Did you, were you just like, okay,
I'm gonna play this game for this long,
block out this time to play game
and block out this amount
of time to like edit this
kind of segment or was it just whatever?
- I don't think I was conscious of it,
but I think it just happened
naturally within my day.
I didn't even go to my
own college graduation
'cause I was like, I
need to edit this video.
So I just got my degree
mailed to me and that was,
and everyone else went out
for like a graduation party
and I was like, I guess I'll
go out for a couple of drinks.
I have to be home to work though.
Like nobody else understood
it at that time right.
- Yeah.
- Now it seems kind
of silly to do.
That's like, yeah, enjoy
yourself and have fun.
But back then, there was no like,
you can't put your foot
in the brake at all.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There was no work like ethos.
- Yeah. You just get lost
and then shuffled in.
- Yeah. Because I was doing my first two
and a half years of YouTube,
I was doing daily uploads as well
while I was a full time uni student.
And the only reason why I
stopped doing daily uploads
is because my computer
literally exploded on me.
Like if my computer had never exploded
and like basically just
completely stopped the ability
to even make videos, then I'd
probably still be doing it
for as long as maybe you did it.
- Yeah.
- But even then, it's
like, I can't imagine.
- You never missed a day for five years.
Was there some days you missed?
- I think so.
I think there was one
day I missed because-
- Holy shit!
- A tree fell down
from a storm and cut out our power.
(laughing)
- It literally took like an act of God
to stop you from uploading.
- Yeah.
My internet was so shit at home as well
that I would take them to college
and upload them on the computer.
- Oh my God.
- Oh, shit.
- I presume, you know,
during the whole five years,
right there was like, I
don't know, two, three years
in you were pretty doing
pretty well for yourself.
Like it was good.
- Yeah, all right.
- So what made you continue
when you had already gotten
to a point that was really successful
that you felt that I
need to keep doing this?
- Well, part of it was the
emotional side of things
where you kind of don't
want to be by yourself.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And all you know is you-
- Yeah, I can attest to that.
- All you know is the noise
and if you're constantly busy,
then nothing can creep up on you.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's true.
- And then, you know,
I think the landscape
had kinda like started to
shift and the demand for,
I think it was like "Life
is Strange I" came out
and Felix did like the
whole chapter in one video.
- Yeah.
- And that was unheard of at the time,
I was like, you fucken idiot.
You gave away all these views.
That could've been like four episodes
and then it paid off so well for him.
And then it was like, oh wait,
watch time is such a big factor
that everyone just started doing it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And you just couldn't
do daily really anymore
if you were doing that.
- Right, right.
So you didn't like you,
did you miss Christmases?
New year's?
Everything?
- Ever?
- Oh my God.
- 'Cause it was always like, well,
well I didn't like work on Christmas.
- Right, right.
(indistinct)
- You'd work ahead for like two days,
but it was like, some people
are alone at Christmas.
I want videos for them to go out.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It was like, I don't wanna
disappoint anybody, right.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. Yeah.
Like they come every day,
like after school or
after college or whatever.
- And I guess that
pressure just kept going
as the subscribe account got higher.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, thank Jesus.
- And then we went to like a
YouTube summit in New York,
in like 2016.
And like me Mark, Felix, like
a whole bunch of Casey IAD
and a whole bunch of
other people were there.
And then my YouTube rep kept
like showing me around
being like, this is Sean.
He is like one of the
fastest growing channels
on the whole platform this year.
And I was like, what?
Like, you didn't fucken tell me that.
And then I went up and like
Susan Wojcicki was there.
And like, my contact
was like, this is Sean.
He runs like Jacksepticeye.
And she was like, and I was like,
okay, so what you're
saying doesn't mean shit.
Right.
I was like, gassing me
up to all these people,
and then you talked to the CEO of YouTube
and they had no idea who I was.
- She did an interview with Ludwig.
That looked pretty good.
She seemed very chill about it.
I don't know if that, cause.
- I guess she wasn't in tune
with the YouTube sphere back then.
- As much as she's had, like
just started to get big.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Since then she's been
very, very nice to me.
And she's had a lot of
good things to say, yeah.
- Yeah.
- She's that one time, forget.
(laughing)
- I want a second play button.
- They say first impressions
don't really matter.
Obviously, Susan, you know it does.
Okay.
- Snap.
She just got blindsided by me.
- Yeah.
Because she's lovely.
- Everyone likes to clown on Susan
for like the CEO of YouTube.
It's like, you think she
knows what's going on?
The ad department don't even talk
to the marketing department at YouTube.
Like no one fucken knows what's going on
at that five four.
- Too fair. I imagine it
when you were at an event
with like every other big
YouTuber, it's unremarkable.
If another YouTuber comes,
It's like, this is another one.
Yeah.
- It's like, you're there at a summit
with like all like some
of the biggest creatives.
What's another one to you?
- One thing I've always wondered is,
so we've talked quite a bit
on the podcast about how,
the reach we have has definitely
like affected our lives,
like off of YouTube and
especially at conventions
and stuff like that.
Like us three put together
is like a fraction
of the reach that you have.
Like how has it affected your life?
Like I'm genuinely curious
about what your lifestyle is like
and how you've had to adapt because of it?
- Yeah, it was a little
weird in the beginning
'cause when you meet fans for
the first time in real life,
it's kind of scary.
And it's like, oh, and I
lived in like a small town
and I was like, oh, they're
gonna find out where I live.
They eventually did.
- Right, right.
- And people show up at my
door like three times a week.
- Like seriously.
- And like what would they ask for,
just like to come in for a couple.
- Yeah.
There was like, there was one
time that I always remember,
'cause I lived in like
a gated apartment area.
Right. And they got in at
like 9:00 a.m. and I was like,
how the fuck did that happen?
It turns out my neighbors let them in.
- 'Cause they said who I
was and they were like,
he loves meeting people.
(laughing)
I was like I don't know you.
And it was like a Polish family,
like a mother and her two kids.
And they had this big wooden board
with like YouTube written
on it and my name.
They were like we wanted
to give this to you.
And I was like standing there
in like my underwear and a shirt,
having just rolled out of bed.
- She in the American action
and just been like, no, no,
this is mark reply.
- I don't speak English.
(laughing)
You should hit them with the Korean.
- But it got really scary at that point.
And then we moved to Brighton
and then I was like militant
about not having my address anywhere
and trying so hard to
like keep things secret.
And I think that that kind of
messed me up for a long time.
Like even when I would stream,
I was so paranoid that I would
like show Amazon or something
and I would have like postcode
- Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
- I've been very terrified
of that too, yeah.
- Yeah. Or anything would
just show up on my desktop
that like give a hint to where I am
or what I'm doing or like even
like the time on my clock.
So I got really paranoid.
- Right, right, right.
- But that was also like fan fervor
and they were all like
really big into like shipping
and really like fanatical
about everything.
- Yeah, that era of YouTube.
- Which is swinging back
now with all the Minecrafts.
- Yeah.
I mean, it's still, it's coming back.
It's coming back.
- It's definitely coming back.
- But thankfully, my audience
have just kinda like matured
with me and kind of settled down and yeah.
I think the main thing
that I got out of it
was that I didn't set
boundaries early enough.
- Right, right, right.
- And I think a lot of people are scared
of setting those boundaries 'cause
it makes their...
They think their audience
are gonna hate them
for doing that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. Like, oh,
you don't want us as close.
You keep saying you love us and yeah.
You actually hate us and you don't want us
to come to your house.
- Yeah.
- No, I don't.
- It's like skipped
about seven steps there.
- Yeah, it was like trying
not to rock the boat at all.
Trying not to piss people off.
- Yeah, because I remember,
I guess people like us have to be thankful
to like the experiences
that you went through
because back then it did very much feel
like the boundary just didn't exist.
And if YouTubers talked about
it, then the consensus was,
well, why are you complaining about this?
This is, this is...
- They made you.
Why aren't you grateful
that fans love you so much, you know?
- I remember that during
the whole like team 10
house, remember that?
There was like so many videos.
'Cause we could put the address in public.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah. It was like a listed Google place.
- Yep.
Yeah.
- And then people would turn up
and they'd be like, no, fuck off.
And then there's just so many
videos of parents being like,
we married you.
Do you know, you wouldn't
be there this without us?
- And they're like, oh my,
- They bought all your shirts.
- Oh my God.
- You literally wouldn't be
in this location without me.
- Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
- I mean, thankfully it does seem like
the mentality because of
so many bad interactions
and bad fan stories that, you know,
people are kind of getting the point now.
So, you know, thankfully.
- I hope so.
- Did you ever have to
look into your security
or anything like that?
Did they ever got to that point?
- No, 'cause everyone was
just so nice about it.
No one was like doing
any nefarious shit to me.
- Right, right. It was
like, like you didn't have
the super weirdos coming up.
- Well, I say that,
but somebody did mail a tub of shit
to like a company address
that I was registered at.
- What?
- Like, it was apparently
there's a website
that you can mail like different
types of shit to people.
So what had showed up at-
- I shouldn't laugh but that's very funny.
- What had showed up at
my house was horse shit.
(laughing)
So you can get pig shit,
cow shit, dog shit.
And that was like, when I was like,
oh, you guys are fucken weird.
- Was it labeled as horse shit or...
- I think so, yeah.
Like it was in like a
Tupperware kind of thing.
- Like here's your tub of horseshit, sir.
- Yeah.
- But it didn't come directly to my house.
I went to like a business
address that I was interested in.
- Right, right.
- How long there
I was like should we throw this away?
And I was like.
- Yeah. So how long did it take you guys
to realize it was horseshit?
It was just sitting there and
just like something smells.
- Time for the taste test.
It was probably after my third
spoonful that I was like.
That's horse shit.
(laughing)
- Rather bizarre phone call to receive
like Jack, we had yeah a box of shit.
Did you order this?
- Because somebody sent
a cake to me before.
- Right.
- And I was like, okay,
I'm not eating that.
Like obviously, oh actually, I did eat it.
That was stupid of me.
That was like-
- I've done that as well.
That was like 2015.
We didn't know that's how we
lent the taste of earlier.
- It was into the cake.
- Wasn't a chocolate cake.
- That was the same story,
just, you know yeah.
- That was at the point,
like those were almost
like back to back where I was like, eh.
- Right, right.
- Was getting weird that
you're sending stuff to me
instead of like showing up at the house.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I think I've seen enough
of like those kinds of videos
and heard enough of those
kinds of stories to know like,
'cause you know, during that
time when you're starting off,
right, like people are like,
oh so like when are
you gonna get a PO box?
- Yeah.
- To like send stuff and
hearing stories like that
from early on, I was like, never did you?
- No, no I had one that
it got really crazy.
- I just imagine it got overrun so fast.
- Yeah, you kind of just think like,
where am I gonna put all this?
- Yeah.
- And yeah.
- Well that happened at conventions.
I would go to conventions and people
would just send us boxes and stuff
or bring them up to the meet and greets.
- Right.
- I paid like hundreds of dollars
to ship it back to my house.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So it was like, these are so many items.
It was like three, three or
four boxes worth of stuff.
And I was like, what I
gonna do with all of this?
And then you run outta
space, then you have to move.
And it's like,
I feel awful having to
like do stuff with this.
And it's like, you don't
wanna like tell people
that you had to like
throw some stuff away,
which is like awful to think about.
And I like literally cried one time.
I was like having to
like put stuff in a bin.
I was like, I let everyone down.
- Oh man.
- Sorry.
Oh man.
- And then now I'm like.
- No.
- But that was the
thing, like no boundary.
And I was like, okay, no
gifts at these things anymore,
'cause I can't do anything with yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, 'cause it's like,
it's more of a logistical thing now where
you literally can't take everything home.
And a lot of it,
especially like food stuff,
it's now like a health and safety concern.
Maybe it's got horse shit in it,
like who fucken knows anymore.
- You never know.
- Someone gives you a COVID cake.
- Oh no.
Yeah.
- That's something I
didn't think we needed
to worry about, until now post-COVID.
- So someone out there's probably like
that's a fantastic idea.
- People who just met you guys,
the karma com were like messed out guys.
That necklace they gave them
could have been a COVID cave.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Just gotta check if anyone's
coughing on their gift
before they give it to you.
- Just like detox, fucken spray your cage.
- You wanna just lather
your cake in hand sanitizer.
- Like early pandemic
when you saw those videos,
people like putting the
hand sanitizer on the apples
and stuff over those,
like what are you doing?
- Fighting COVID that's a good.
- In just a bizarre way, yeah.
- Not getting COVID but
eating hand sanitizer
at the same time, yeah.
- Have you had like,
aside from getting horse shit sent to you,
have he had any weird fan interactions?
Just like at conventions or at
events or anything like that?
- Oh, yeah.
'Cause he used to go to
quite a few conventions.
- Yeah, I think I'm done with them now.
I think Pop Con in 2020
was like right at the
start of the pandemic,
like a week after that was
when lockdown happened.
- Right.
- And I got violently ill.
So think I got COVID like
right at the beginning.
- At that time, no one was testing that.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, some people had like
pulled out a VidCon for that.
And after that I was like,
I risked dying for a
convention and I was like,
maybe it's not worth it.
- Right.
- And then I'm like, when people go there,
they don't really get an
interaction with you anymore.
'Cause it's like someone's
there with a timer
for like 30 seconds.
And it's like a picture shake.
Thank you.
Bye.
I don't wanna meet people that way.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
- What's the VidCon
experience like, because none-
- Yeah, I also have to say like,
I've only heard the most
fucking wild things from people,
whether it be positive or negative.
- Here wasn't so bad
'cause I think people here
have a different culture and
a different sort of mindset.
Like Europeans are a bit
calmer than Americans would be.
I'm not stereotyping, you fuckin' are.
I've done a tour in the whole world.
I know what you people act like.
But in VidCon, in LA
was fucken batchy crazy.
It was like the walking dead.
- This just, it just scary.
- It was terrifying.
We weren't allowed out onto the main hall
'cause you just weren't.
They have like a couple of hours scheduled
after one of the days
where creators can go out
and experience it, which
there was nothing to do there.
It's like there was a
Snapchat booth and like a-
- I did see it, it looked very anemic,
I have to mention that.
- Yeah.
It's mention it's very corporate
and it's very like branded
and it's very kind of boring
for anyone who's there.
So people are just there to see creatives.
And then like, as that was happening,
we got to walk down the main
hall and all these fans,
like hundreds of them at the window,
like faces pressed to it.
- Oh my God.
- And we witnessed such a dead, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
It just sounds like oh gosh.
So sad.
- We went to like the Gregory
brothers concert and we went,
I went the wrong way
'cause no one was like
ushering us a different way.
People like literally like grabbed us
and pulled us back out of the group.
- Wow.
- And then we like,
I went with like Matt and
Ryan from super mega one year.
- Yeah, right.
- And we walked around the
back and we were out like
in the apartment area of,
and walking around and some fan was like,
I had like a hat, I had a mask,
I had my hood up and somebody was like,
oh, I knew it was you from your walk.
I was like, this is.
- Oh my God.
- I've walked in a video.
So I'm like, how did you recognize me?
So after that, I was like,
maybe don't do VidCon again.
- Right.
Yeah, 'cause that's pretty much
the experience we've heard.
And that's like, it's a
convention where, you know,
as a YouTuber, you think you
need to go to at least once.
But every YouTube I've talked
to has been like, you know,
you don't need to go to VidCon.
- Pax was great though.
I have so many fond memories of Pax
and like, I don't wanna seem all negative.
Like all my interactions were bad,
but people at Pax are absolutely.
- I've heard good things about Pax.
- Yeah.
And they'd wait in line
for like seven hours
and they'd be starving.
And then just for a
chance to like talk to you
and then it was so sweet and
talk about how much you changed
their life and everything.
And we were like, those
would always go on.
It was like scheduled for two hours
and they'd go on for like
five 'cause it's like,
you just wanna actually meet
these people and interact.
They're all lovely.
- Yeah, I mean hearing you
say that people in Europe
and people in the UK are a lot chiller
compared to people in America,
like terrifies the shit outta me
because we just went to a
convention last weekend.
And literally in that one convention,
like a random guy just went up on stage
on our panel and sat next to Joey.
And that was like, to me,
like I'd never dealt with
anything like that in my life.
- Extremely traumatized, that's for sure.
So I'm just like, if
it's like that in the UK,
how is it gonna be located
in America?
- Assuming there don't
have too many of them here.
- Yeah, yeah, maybe it might be that.
- It's the first one we've done.
- Literally the first one
we've done, so we've...
- Like it's now we're never.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So it's basically like a learning.
It's been like a learning
experience for us as well.
- Did you go to Indie Pop Con?
Is that one that you went to?
- Oh yeah.
- See, okay.
I think I went the year after you.
- Oh.
(Jack laughs)
- And it was like this really
weird thing where it was like,
we do not talk about what
happened last year. (laughing)
Genuinely.
It'd be like, yeah.
If Indie Pop Con, all the
staff were like, yeah,
it's been really good working
here except for last year.
- Yeah.
- We had Markiplier and
Jack in the same building
and it was like-
- Oh, shit!
- They said that they were basically,
the message that I heard.
Maybe you can confirm.
I just wanna know this personally.
I don't give a shit about that.
They basically said that like
they were extremely woefully unprepared
is the message that I heard.
Yeah.
- And we went, I was like 2015
or 2016, I can't remember.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And it was
the second convention I ever went to
and it was me, Mark, Bob
and Wade all like in a line
and people all day just
lined up to meet us.
Some people would come
back multiple times.
We didn't have like a
way to figure it out.
- Right.
- And people were just coming endlessly.
Like the first day we
signed for nine hours.
- Fuck, hell.
- We had no food,
no breaks, no anything.
- Gosh, Jesus.
- Then the next day we went again,
and over like the three-day weekend,
we did 21 hours of signing.
- Jesus!
- Did they never cap
the line or anything like that?
- There was no capping.
There was no like lottery
system to let people in.
Like everyone was lovely, but it was like,
we just didn't know what to do with it.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, nine hours.
Oh my God.
I can't even like fathom that.
- Like if you just get to
the convention sign all day,
go to dinner and then do
it again for two more days.
It was brutal.
- Yeah, 'cause like I guess was,
is that like a common experience
with conventions with you,
especially in the early days?
'Cause I feel like with you being part
of like the early generation
of YouTubers where, you know,
you started seeing the
massive reach that you did.
A lot of people were just
like, from what I've heard,
just didn't expect you
guys to like have the reach
or just have the fan
engagement that you did.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause it was at Indie Pop Con.
They have a lot of like,
like movie stars and like.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And TV stars.
And they do signings where it's paid for.
- Right, right.
- And so we were like,
we don't wanna charge
fans to like meet us.
It's like I wouldn't pay to meet me.
- Yeah. (laughing)
- So we were like,
we'll just do it for free.
And like let people come.
So it was like anybody who
was anybody was like there,
if they wanted to meet someone,
but didn't wanna pay.
- Right.
- Some of those people
didn't even know who we were.
They were like someone will know.
Who just came up to like
take pictures and stuff.
- Yeah, 'cause I guess
like even back then,
especially back then as well,
like I think just the general consensus
of famous YouTubers being at
a con was just like, oh yeah.
You know, they just
like make videos online,
how famous could they possibly be,
compared to like these
people who have been
in Hollywood and TV and stuff like that.
- Yeah, and little did
I guess Indy Pop Con.
- Yeah.
- We kept like sniping
people from those lines.
And then all the people who
were like had paid signings,
got mad at us and were like.
- Yeah, that's happening as well.
- Yeah.
They were like giving it away for free.
Like of course, no one's
gonna come to my booth now.
And I'm like, I just wanna have fun, man.
- Some of them do charge
like outrageous prices.
- Yeah, it was ridiculous.
- Like 80 pounds for an autograph.
And it's like, what?
- And you didn't even like really get
to meet them for very long.
It was like an autograph
and a picture and then buy.
- Yeah.
- Don't pay for that.
(laughing)
I don't think anyone's worth that.
- You're better than that.
- [All] Yeah.
- 'Cause I feel like I dunno
how it would be in Japan,
but I feel like there's very
much like a culture in Japan
where you might very much
like pay for something to get
to see this celebrity or this idol.
definitely like idol culture, right?
- The illustrious handshake of events.
Right.
- Idols, yeah.
- I saw the weirdest thing
actually now that you say that
in Japan where we were
like next to a theater.
It wasn't like a,
I don't think it was like a
Kabuki theater or whatever.
There's like a term for it.
And I can't remember what it is.
- Like a traditional
theater type of thing?
- It was like, God, I'm
trying to like find the words
without seeming offensive.
It was like-
- Fine, it's fine.
- Yeah, I think it was like a thing
where like ladies would dress up
as like guys and like have
like really impressive makeup
and everything done.
- Oh!!
- Was that drag?
- No, no, no.
It's Takarazuka.
- Yeah.
- Takarazuka.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, and our hotel was like right next
to a Takarazuka theater,
and there was like
dozens of people lined up
outside every evening.
And people would come out
and just like, say hi.
And they were all in line.
They all like stood up one by
one, all perfectly in unison.
It was like a swim team,
like perfectly choreographed.
- Like synchronized swimming.
- But they were like so
respectful and they were like,
let's not do anything on our
end to like piss them off
or they'll never do this again.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And they would come out
and they would like wave
to everybody down the line all the way.
And that would happen for
like a couple of hours.
And then everyone would
like, everyone would leave.
And then they were like, okay, we're done.
Like fan club go home.
- Right, right.
- Fan culture in Japan is like next level.
- Yeah.
- Take it to like the limit.
Or what is a Takarazuka theater?
- Takarazuka is like, it's this basically
this like very trad,
I don't know a whole lot about it myself,
but basically it's been
around for, I think,
close to like a century.
And it's this like specific
type of, as you said,
is a specific type of like
stage performance thing
that has like very high regard
and high like loyalty status basically,
of like basically like really acclaimed
female stage actresses dress up basically.
They kind of cross-play as
like males and you know,
it's kind of like think
of like, if I don't know,
a traditional Shakespearean
play was happening,
but all of the stage
performers are female.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- So like all the guy
characters are female,
all the female characters are female.
And it's yeah.
It's like kind of a musical
slash stage play kind of thing.
A very, very popular in Japan
for a very specific demographic, I feel.
- Right.
- Yeah, mostly like, you know,
kind of like women
between ages like 20 to 50
are like really, really into it.
But yeah.
- It was cool though.
Like it's really cool.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Some of them would still come out
with like some of the makeup still on.
It was really impressive. And
then we like looked it up,
like when we were back to
the hotel to figure out
what's going on and like
the outfits are insane.
The choreography's insane.
- A lot of money goes into it.
It's some of the highest
paid stage performers,
I think in the world are at Takarazuka.
- But I just couldn't
get my head around it.
I was like trying to
figure out what it was.
- Just like coming out and dress this guy.
- I'm trying to figure out the...
And I don't wanna just say
it's women dressing up as guys.
Like, obviously, there's more to it.
- From a surface, that's
what it looks like.
- If you don't know, you don't know.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, it's fine, yeah.
- I'm not a horrible
piece of shit, I swear.
Please don't cancel me.
- I don't know how many Takarazuka fans
we have watching this show.
You know, I feel the
demographic is very different.
- The one person who knows
what you're talking about
just raises their hand.
- And just like, like actually I work
in Takarazuka, very offensive.
- I've tapped into that niche for you.
Subscribers are just gonna go up.
- Would you ever wanna go back to Japan?
- Oh yeah, definitely.
Yeah, we wanna go,
like we were gonna say as soon
as the border is open
for like casual visitors.
- Whenever the fuck that happens.
- Yeah.
- Apparently it happened
like very recently.
- Yeah.
- And it's already shut down.
But I was like, it's coming up to summer.
I don't really wanna be there for you.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, you don't wanna be there.
- I mean, again, that's
why we are here right now
so that we are not there.
- Yeah.
- Like, 'cause my, again,
my girlfriend lived there
for like seven years.
So she was like, oh, she kept
trying to like warn Felix.
Yeah.
- I've been trying to warn
Felix the entire time.
But like Felix is like,
oh no, I love summer.
You're not going to after this.
- Yeah, like even for me, 'cause I'm Thai.
So I've spent a lot of
my life in Thailand.
I thought I'm prepared
for Japanese summer.
I know what a hot, humid
Southeast Asian country is like,
it's going to be fine.
And I remember spending my first year,
my first summer in Japan
and I wanted to die.
Nothing even from like Thailand
had prepared me for Japanese summer.
Which is like, it blows
my mind because, you know,
in winter it's so cold there it's so like,
at least in Southeast Asia
you have like one climate,
you know, you have two climates,
it's like hot and humid or
wet and humid, you know?
Right, right.
But in Japan you have
like every single climate
on every single extreme of
like the weather as well.
So it's just yeah.
Japanese summers are no joke.
I swear to God.
- I went to Korea for
a summer and a winter
and it's the same thing
where I was just ball
sweatingly just awful.
- Yeah.
- And I was
like ball freezingly cold.
- Yeah, I couldn't eat.
My appetite was gone and my
girlfriend at the time was like,
yeah, what's wrong?
Like, are you sick?
And I was like, I think
so like what is happening?
It's like walking through like wet air.
- Sauna.
You're just in a sauna just constantly.
It's awful.
- It's like you breathe the air
and is why is the air heavy?
You know, it's heavy air.
- Why is there thick air out here?
- And then you go into any building
and they just blast the shit out
of this cold air and then you're cold.
So you're like, oh I
have to go outside to,
you know, get rid of it.
- And like the, oh sorry, go on.
- For winters then is just
the complete flip of that
where it's like just snow everywhere.
Everything's hard and icy.
And the wind just stabs you in the chest.
- And then you go inside
just sweating there also.
- Yeah.
- The struggles of being from
like this part of the world.
Any weather is like, what the fuck?
- Yeah.
I mean, it's not mild.
- It was 22 degrees. (laughing)
What is happening?
- That's why this weekend
was such a shock to me
'cause everyone, 'cause you know,
this was only my second time in the UK.
And everyone was like,
when I tweeted out saying I'm
gonna to the UK this weekend,
everyone was like, "Oh, enjoy the weather.
'Cause it's gonna be shit."
Meanwhile, it was like
amazing fucken weather.
And I'm like, this is shit to you guys.
- Really good.
It's pretty good, it was great.
- It's been really good.
- But also like UK's the type
of place where you can have...
In Japan, you already have
to like choose your fashion
about what you wear depending
on the weather or something.
In the UK, you're like 90%
of the time of the year
like is it quiet weather
or is it jacket weather?
The answer is yes.
You like, you can get
away with much less choice
into the UK compared to what
you do in Japan, you know?
- Yeah, definitely.
Definitely.
- So, I mean, I've seen a bunch of clips
of you speaking Korean
and I think it just kind
of surprises people.
It surprised me.
'Cause you just don't
expect people to just,
"Hey, I speak some Korean."
(speaks Korean)
- I'm lost in the Korean.
- I know enough to like trick people
into thinking that I know way more.
- That's how it is with
every foreign language there.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So we had some friends,
we were to Japan recently and
they don't know any Japanese
and they think I know a lot more than I do
just 'cause you can get through
the kind of standard flow of conversation.
- Right, right.
- Where it's like,
you know what they're gonna
ask and what they're gonna say.
- Right.
- For all I know, you
could have just said,
I wanna fall on your face.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I don't know.
- Leave a comment for us.
- Sometimes, you know, people
like, what did they just say?
I'm like, I don't have a fucken clue,
but I have enough rough idea.
- Right.
I mean, a lot of it is
like body language as well.
- Right, yeah.
- And that was the thing,
like when I went to Korea,
well, I went to Korea
because I met a girl online from Korea.
Like it was like a pen
pals called Interpals.
- Oh right.
- And I was like international pen pals.
- Right.
- And I had just dropped outta college
for like sound engineering.
And I was like, I dunno what
the I'm doing with my life.
I hate it, maybe I'll take a
gap year, what am I gonna do?
Travel?
I don't wanna go anywhere.
And then doing that was like, oh,
here's a part of the world.
Like Asia had always
kinda like fascinated me
for the longest time.
- Yeah.
- And I had heard "Lost" was out
and they had like Korean
actors in it and I was like,
God, the language is so cool.
And I was like, I wanna
meet people from Korea
and talk to them.
And then one thing led to another
and we started like dating.
- Right.
- And then I went
to visit her a few times
and right now I was like,
I dunno what I was doing.
I dunno what I expected.
- So you watched "Lost" and
you thought that sounds cool.
And that's how you
started learning Korean.
- Yeah.
- Wow.
How many years you've been studying it
for like kind of roughly talking it?
- It was like four years back then.
- Oh wow.
- It was from like
20 to like 20.
It was like around like 19 to 23-ish.
- Doing like lessons or
just literally just talking.
Just all on my own.
- Wow.
- Right.
- Right, we would like talk to each other
on like instant messenger and stuff.
And it was a lot of, it
was all, it was like,
Romanized like Korean.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It was never like the actual alphabet.
It was just her writing stuff in English.
- Right.
- And I would learn it
so much faster that way.
And I think I just picked
up on things quickly anyway.
- That's good.
- Yeah. And then when I
went there was like, oh,
now I get everything
'cause fucken textbooks
are always like, can you point
me to the nearest embassy?
It's like, hello.
This is a pen.
- Yeah.
So being there, it was like,
it was all like body language
and like seeing how they emoted and-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And like just being
surrounded by the alphabet
and like seeing it on stores
and like trying to read it all the time,
it just accelerates things so much faster.
- When we had Kevin on,
Kevin speaks some pretty good Japanese
and he said the best way that he learned
was just getting drunk
and trying to speak it.
- Yeah.
- And yeah, I think that helped me a lot
with Japanese as well.
- Yeah.
Just getting drunk cause you
don't care that you're up.
- Yeah.
I would just kind be like be
in her house with her family
and they would have like
(speaks Japanese) on like
in "Running Man" and stuff.
And I was like, I have
no idea what's going on,
but you can just,
you can tell what's happening
just through body language.
- Right, right.
- I would like pick up words
here and there from what I knew.
- And you got checked
in the deep end, then?
- Yeah.
These are my parents.
- Talk to them.
- Oh God, oh God.
- And I made like the,
oh the worst mistake,
which is like not putting
yo at the end of words,
'cause I got so casual with her.
- Right, right.
- Right. Right.
And I was, and then I was like gomawo
and then she was like gomawoyo.
And I was like, I'm never
speaking this to you.
I fucked up the most basic thing ever.
My manners were out the window,
but it was a cool learning experience.
I think it matured me very quickly.
- Right.
- Seeing like another part
of the world, I was like,
I think that's what I've
learned over YouTube
is like seeing so many like
races, ethnicities, genders.
- Yeah.
- Like skin colors,
like religious beliefs.
I was like, yeah.
It like broadens your world so far.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That you can't like
internalize your problems
to adjust yourself anymore.
- Do you think learning
Korean has helped you,
like say understand their culture more
when you were over there?
'Cause I feel like we've
had this discussion before,
but I feel like part of a culture
is ingrained in their language.
- Yeah.
- And you might be able
to like sympathize with some culture,
but like empathizing with
them through like language
is just like a different,
different level I think.
- Yeah, 'cause they have
like honorific systems
and everything and like treating
older people a certain way.
And that obviously isn't
ingrained in our culture here.
- Yeah, yeah.
- No.
- Fuck it (indistinct)
(laughing)
- Yes, we can't.
Yeah, we don't do we really?
No, we don't.
No, it's different.
- Yeah.
I was trying to think like you should.
- You mean kind of, but not to that level.
- Yeah.
- Do you speak any Gaelic at all?
- Not really, no.
- I speak Welsh and there's a kind
of honorific word system.
- You're fluent in Welsh?
- Yeah, native, yeah.
I went to Welsh schools and
did all my exams in Welsh.
- What is "How are you?" In Welsh?
(speaks Welsh)
- It's conas tatu in Irish.
- Oh, okay.
- So I'm trying to see
where the connection is.
- But we have so many Ls and stuff.
- Right.
- We have the long town name,
the (speaks Welsh)
- Okay, he was just getting prepared.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like layering his story.
- So you have ""Berserk"",
I have Ryan Reynolds, you have Welsh.
- I'm (indistinct)
- Before the end of this podcast,
you'll be the boss to your flex.
- Yeah, I mean in Welsh,
there's the honorifics of kind
of like how casual do you speak to them?
Whereas you say Tiki or Ti
- Yeah, I'm so bad at Irish
that I wouldn't even be able to tell.
- Yeah, we learned it in school,
but like no one really speaks it enough
in the part of Ireland that I was in,
unless you're studying it, right.
- I think, I dunno,
correct me if I'm wrong.
I think Welsh language,
the government tries
their God hardest to get more fluency.
It's taken like really seriously in Wales
and they're really like
passionate about it.
It seems that Ireland, they still are,
but not to the same extent as-
- Yeah, the west of Ireland is pretty,
I guess Wales is west in the,
that region of the country as well.
- Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
- I think, I don't know.
I think just 'cause not
enough people speak it
and we've integrated
into the world better.
Like with English, I think.
- Right.
- And I don't know,
I shouldn't speak about my own culture,
'cause I'm so unknowledgeable about it.
- I can't remember, in Ireland,
all the road signs in Gaelic and English.
- Yeah.
- Welsh it's the same.
- All in Welsh and English.
- And like on the coins,
there's like Irish on them
and like notes and stuff.
So we have some of it there,
but we're not like
reinforcing it very well.
- Right, right.
- I found out that it meant
for all the English money
is in Wales and I thought,
how did they let that happen?
Why haven't we taken it all?
Like we need some of it.
Well, there's none of it in Wales.
- If Ireland had that,
we wouldn't have got the Republic back.
(laughing)
- We're not using this
as negotiating power.
Why are we not using this?
- Brexit happened, you guys
didn't lord that over their head
and be like, yeah, say it again.
- [Connor] I did.
- Yeah.
- I'm surprised you in
Scotland didn't rise up.
- Actually the worst part is,
is that Wales was like very much for it.
Even though Wales benefited so much
from getting help from the EU, but-
- It was a mess.
- It was, it's a sad time.
- I don't think many people
knew what was going on.
- No.
- I was actually at that VidCon
that I was talking about
in LA when it happened.
- That must have been so-
- Oh really?
We're going to a party in the news bro.
And we were like, well, time to drink.
- Let's forget about.
- I feel like it became, it
was, it was about Brexit,
but it was about so much
more different things
for the voters than what
it actually was about
as it has become.
And yeah, it's not that.
- Yeah, I mean, I remember I was
in America at the time as well.
I was staying at my, you know,
now fiance's place and-
- There's your flex.
- Yeah.
- He's getting married, that's oh.
- Yeah!
- It's your birthday.
- Hey, it's my birthday today.
- Right?
That's all you get, though.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- And yeah, I remember
like seeing it on the news
and I'm just like, it was like 50 50,
and I'm like, I'm gonna go to bed.
And like when I wake up, I'll
wake up to like the good news-
- Or a bad dream.
(laughing)
- And I remember still like waking up,
seeing on my phone and I'm just like,
I must have like been dreaming.
I've like obviously seeing this wrong
and I like refresh, refresh my brain.
And I just stared at it for
like a good, like two minutes.
And I just couldn't fucken believe it.
- Expand the top like inception,
expand the top and inception.
- At least you get the
Irish passport though.
So you don't have to-
- Yeah, that's true.
- Your passport doesn't just become shit.
- Yeah, and in the YouTube space,
it doesn't really affect us that much.
- True.
- Yeah.
- Unless an importing vegetables.
(laughs)
- Oh, shit.
Pay VAT on it.
- Yeah, but my coffee
doesn't ship to England
as easily now.
- Oh.
- Okay, I actually wanna ask about that.
Why coffee?
Why is that the, is it
to kind of stand out?
You were like, ah, fuck it, not merch.
- Because like cloak makes sense, right?
Because you know, that's
a thing, that's a move
I think that YouTubers have been trying
to make for a very...
I mean, I also made that move as well.
But like the coffee thing, I
think no one was expecting.
- Yeah, I just really liked
coffee for a really long time.
And I initially was like thinking
of whiskey and I was like
that would've made...
- Sounds sticky though.
YouTube or whiskey is that?
- Yeah, and it's just so much harder,
like there's actual like laws around it.
- Yeah.
- I was like my audience
probably wouldn't even,
like 40% of them probably
wouldn't even be able to drink it.
- Right, right.
- Getting it to different
places would be impossible.
And then I was like,
I kept thinking about
coffee and I was like,
what if we made like top
of the morning coffee?
I was like, oh, okay.
That fucken name is too
good, I have to do it.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- And then it was a part of that,
nobody else was doing it and I was like,
it sets me apart from other people
and it's different than just
doing merch and clothes.
- Right, right.
- It's just a fun thing
that I had no idea about and
like learning how it was made
and that I just had my own coffee.
Then I could, if it sustains itself,
I get free coffee all the time now.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Extremely successful, I assume.
- Yeah, thank you.
- Thank you, I get free coffee every day.
- Was there any challenges
that you didn't anticipate
starting a company like this
that has like nothing to do with YouTube?
- Yeah, initially it
was like, coffee's like
a food item.
So it has to be shipped as
fresh and quick as possible.
- Right.
- So, when we started
the shipping to England
was a nightmare
'cause we have to pay import
charges and everything.
- Right.
- And it would take like a
month to get it to people.
And then it would cost extra.
So shipping here would
cost like twice as much
as the coffee itself.
- Right.
- Hm.
- And it was like starting a company,
you have to start really small,
especially when it's something
that you haven't done before.
And we had no like infrastructure
really for it initially.
So we it's made in America
and it's made in Nebraska and stuff.
- Yeah.
- And it was shipping from there
and that was the only
place it was shipping from.
So we had to figure out a new method
to get it to people cheaper.
- Right.
- Which we thankfully did.
And all that feedback initially
was like really, really helpful.
But as soon as it went up,
everyone was super pumped about it.
And then all that day I was miserable.
'Cause everyone was like
it just fucken sucks,
it's so expensive.
It doesn't ship here, you don't have this.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like the site went down
and I spent the whole day being like, man,
I spent so long like prepping this
and I got so like
emotionally attached to it.
And I was like trying to
like put out fires all day.
- Yeah.
- No matter how much
you make your merch though,
there's always that,
oh, it's too expensive.
- Expensive, yeah.
- Of course, oh yeah.
I mean, we don't have this
like gigantic west system
in every single town we go to Walmart.
We can't just get shit
to you extremely cheap.
- Well, that was the thing is
like trying to educate people
while also like sympathizing with them
and trying to meet them
halfway with everything.
And like not trying not to
get too businessy with them.
- Right.
- Listen, the breakdown cost right now.
- I can show you our
profit and loss account.
We're in debt.
- Like I guess I wonder as a YouTuber,
how'd you even like start to like...
like yeah...
Coffee guy.
Okay, because like, I think, okay.
Maybe like one day maybe it'll start
like the "Trash Taste" coffee company.
I don't know what it's gonna be called,
but like, okay.
So there, I'll just phone my coffee go.
Who do I?
- Who's the coffee guy?
- Who do I talk to?
- Coffee supply.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like where do we even like start?
- Let's go to Ethiopia
to get those fresh beans.
- Just like meet a dude who
was like, oh, by the way,
I'm very interested in
starting a coffee company.
- Well, there was a
company that was doing it
with Brooke Dodger.
- Right.
- Oh, okay.
- And then they were doing
it with Smash as well.
And that was another thing,
like a review for the coffee
came out and somebody was like,
it was like a big coffee guy on YouTube.
And I have his book,
he taught me so much about coffee
and I thought he was great.
And then he was like
"YouTubers getting into coffee.
What does the business look like?"
And it was all like,
he didn't actually start
his own coffee company.
Like he used this other company
to like source the beans and everything.
And I was like, yeah, I said that.
(laughing)
I don't think I was dishonest.
Like, did people think I was gonna like go
to the farm myself and like pay for like-
- You do generic business videos
if you just like touching the beans in.
- Just like, yeah.
Handpicked by Jacksepticeye.
I did start a company
that has like its own official documents.
And I didn't like buy a
roastery on my own roasters.
(laughing)
Like I think they expected
a bit more out of it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But yeah, they were like handling coffee
for people already.
And we were, my agents
at the time were like,
they just do everything for everybody.
- Right.
- Right, right.
- And they kind of knew a couple of people
who were starting coffee
companies already.
And they were like,
we can put you in touch
with all these people
and then Cura coffee,
who are doing the one that
is we're working with now.
They had done Dodgers.
And when I talked to them,
they just seemed so genuine
and nice and open about
it and they got it.
And it wasn't all about
like cranking money
outta people and-
- Right, right.
- It was just really honest,
like genuine fun to do.
- So now the question
is how did Dodger get in touch with that?
- Yeah, we'll go back the line.
- We'll work our way up.
- Yeah, exactly.
- But technically, yeah, I
had a coffee guy that I...
- Yeah, okay.
That definitely makes things a lot easier.
- There's always somebody
who knows somebody you know
who'll put you in touch
with the right people.
- Yeah.
- And if not, you can
always just tweet it out.
- Hey, I wanna find someone
who can maybe source me some coffee.
- See like, I've tried
that few times where,
where you're just you need a
guy and like you tweet it out.
Is there any, and like you
get everything, but that guy.
Most of the tweets are just like,
I'm not the guy, but good luck.
And I'm just like,
why are you applying
to this Twitter thread?
- I Know.
Or it's always like, I'm not that guy,
but I do have a Fiverr account.
I can make you some artwork
for it if that's okay with you.
And I'm like, thanks, but no, thanks.
- Here's my fan cam that I did. (laughing)
- Yeah.
That's cool though.
- One, one thing I want to know.
- Right.
- Is why did you decide
to move to Brighton?
Because I wanna know this-
- As a Brighton resident.
- Well, I wanna know this
as someone who was born
and raised in Brighton and like, you know,
I grew up-
- Didn't know that, that's cool.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So, you know, I still technically live
in Brighton when-
- Another flex.
(indistinct)
- But yeah, like I remember
when Brighton was a town,
it wasn't even a city, it was a town.
And now seeing like growing
up and now seeing, you know,
big YouTubers coming there
and like, it's the cool city,
it's the cool hip city.
Like I wanted to know,
like you personally,
since you being such a big presence there,
in terms of like content creators
who have moved to Brighton,
what made you decide to do so?
- I think 'cause Felix
lived there for a long time
and I had heard really
nice things from him
and then like Alfie and
those guys were there
and there was a couple of other,
like big YouTubers were there.
- A lot of them were there.
- And I didn't really get it.
When I went there, I realized, oh,
it's like a mini L.A.,
now I kind of get it.
- Right, right, right.
- So sort
of structured but smaller.
And I went there to visit
him for the first time,
over like a weekend in October,
like years and years ago.
And then I just fell in
love with it immediately.
'Cause I'd been thinking
about moving already.
And I was like LA's a bit too far.
It's a bit too crazy.
- Yeah, yeah.
You have to get visas and everything.
And I was like, I kind of maybe London
and then London was
just a fucken nightmare.
The traffic's awful.
There's too many people here.
It's just, it was a bit too
busy for someone who grew up
in a tiny town. And then
when I went to Brighton,
I was like, this is lovely.
This is like small, the
beach is there if we want it,
oh friends are there.
- I'm feeling so prideful right now, man.
I'm feeling so prideful,
I'm like, yeah, it is.
Yeah, it is.
- Just, the people were just so nice.
And like, it was like a really
strong like LGBTQ there.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And everybody was just so
like progressive and nice.
The vegan community was huge there.
And I was like, this is perfect.
Why would I live anywhere else?
- And yeah.
- Just walking around town
was a very walkable city
and it was just really fun to do.
- But you don't get like bombarded
if you feel like walking around town.
- No.
- Really?
- Oh wow, okay.
- Everyone's pretty chilled in Brighton.
- Oh yeah.
- I mean, people come up and
ask for pictures and stuff,
but if you say no,
they're like, yeah, okay.
Whatever you say.
- Yeah, 'cause it was really weird for me
because obviously now that
I came back from, you know,
living in Japan for two years
and we started this podcast
and before that, I didn't
share my face on camera.
And like for the first time,
I started to get recognized
in this home city
that I like grew up in.
So I would've thought
that you would've gotten recognized a lot
or it would've been like
a daily occurrence, so-
- Yeah, I think initially
when I moved it probably was,
but then now people know you're there.
They kind of just-
- Right.
- Like there's
no sense of urgency, right.
- Right, right, right, right.
- Some people still have
to like you look familiar,
but then they don't really
go any further than that.
(laughing)
Yeah, I guess like different
sensibility as well.
- We were saying you
were a versus America.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- People here aren't as starstruck.
Yeah.
- I don't think so.
You guys, Brighton's a cool city.
Come visit Brighton.
It's amazing city.
- No don't, you'll ruin it.
(laughing)
It's nice, I like it.
- Don't make it to VidCon.
Yeah.
- We thought about that
for a while as well.
Like maybe we'll move to L.A. still
and Brighton's just nice.
- Right.
- Every time we come back,
it's like, man, we have a nice house.
We live in a nice part of town.
The people are cool.
The restaurants are really nice.
- Yeah, like L.A. just
seems intense, you know,
from my experience with it.
- It's too city, I feel.
And especially the culture behind it
is definitely, you know,
I feel run by this like,
you know, stardom culture.
- So it's (indistinct)
- Yeah, exactly, exactly.
- Doesn't really 'cause
I said it before that,
when I went on tour,
you get a good sense of like life
in different pockets of the world.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And then like going around
different states, I was like,
oh this is kind of like that state,
but you guys do this instead
and you kinda get a feel
for the culture a bit.
Everything still felt like
quintessentially America.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- But then L.A.is just a different beast.
It feels like we would go down the streets
and like walk around and you
can get a sense for the place,
like who's walking around
and who lives there,
and like they're just a slice of life.
- Yeah.
- But LA is so hard
to find that with.
Anywhere you walk in it,
which is very few places.
It feels like everyone's
just there to work,
even no one lives there.
- Yeah, like every time I
meet like someone in L.A.,
you just get used to people
introducing themselves,
then saying what they do immediately.
- Right.
- You know, normally
that's like a few layers
down in the conversation,
but in L.A., it feels like,
okay, I'm this person,
by the way, I also do this.
I'm working on this, this, this.
And that's just like,
that was just like
very forward for me.
- Working on screenplay.
- Sorry?
- I got propositioned one in an Uber in LA
and then on the same trip,
we heard a guy walking down
the street and it was like,
I just don't think they're
gonna go for that screenplay.
Maybe if we pitched on
this other one, I was like,
no fucken way people talk like this.
I was like are we in a movie?
- Walk on set.
- Yeah.
You're in like the traffic and
that someone like practicing
their lines in the car
next to you or something.
- Yeah, exactly, yeah.
- Did you hear horror stories
of people who move there
and then like change and become Hollywood?
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I think it's impossible not to.
That was another thing.
I was kind of afraid to
move there in case I did-
- Become this monster.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
- 'Cause I'm a sponge, I'll
just take in what's around me.
And I'm like, if I'm surrounded
by that all the time,
that's all you know, and-
- Yeah, yeah.
It's very disconnected
from the rest of the world.
If you like, when we come
back here and we live here,
it's like, people don't talk the same.
They're not talking about
stocks all the time.
Like investing in houses and-
- Scrap the next topic, then-
(laughing)
- I think that's like another big reason
why like I probably could
never see myself living
in a place like that
'cause it's like, yeah.
Again, like I don't wanna be that guy.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Who turns into that, right?
- Yeah.
- Like, love all the people.
I love all my friends that live in L.A.
- For sure.
- They're all amazing people.
But you know, at the same time, yeah,
it is kind of like another world.
- Yeah.
- It doesn't feel real.
- I mean I have so many friends there
and so many of them just
complain about L.A. all the time.
Like they don't even want to be there.
- But they can't leave.
- Yeah, it's hard to get out.
- Well, it's the best place
for this type of work.
- It is.
- I'm never more productive
than when I go to LA.
- [All] Yeah, it's true.
- There's always something that
you can be working on from-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Infinite connections, right?
- Yeah, I feel like if
you want to network,
then L.A. is the place to be.
- Yeah.
- But at what cost?
- Is there no part of you that ever wanted
to try living in Korea for a bit?
- I don't think so.
I think it's too much of
a culture shift for me.
- That's right.
- Makes sense.
And I'm a very social person
and I feel like I would not integrate
as much as I would want to.
- [All] Right.
- I feel like I would be
very scared and nervous
to speak Korean to people.
And I would never go out
and join like a book club
or go meet people at like an
event or anything like that.
- Right.
- That's right, right, right.
- True, true.
- It would be scary.
- Would you ever, are you planning to,
I guess like stay in UK and Ireland then?
Do you see yourself sticking
around this kind of area?
- I think it's nice enough.
I think if we've carved out like
a nice, niche place for us here.
And I think, again, it
keeps me very like grounded
and keeps me like very
in touch with the world.
- Yeah.
- And like walking around
here and in Brighton,
I feel like I'm actually like a part
of like the bigger picture in a weird way.
- No, that's awesome.
- It doesn't feel like a
bubble, like everywhere else,
but I've done LA for like
three months at one point.
And it was really fun.
I had a lot of friends
there and like every night
was to hang out with so many
good restaurants in L.A.
- Yeah, that is one thing that
every time I go back to L.A.,
I'm looking forward to
the restaurant and foods.
- Yeah, it's like the only
place outside of Korea
that has good Korean barbecue.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Korean barbecue's so good.
- Korean barbecue is really good.
- I'm so excited for that like,
'cause we're going to LA
actually in about two weeks,
two, three weeks.
- From recording, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, from a
time with this recording
and the first place I always wanna hit up
is the Korean barbecue.
- Of course, then you can
eat meat. It's just insane.
You get it in Japan, it's
like all you can eat maybe.
Maybe if you are lucky and wear nice.
- Well, Korean barbecue,
I feel is very different
to like Yucky Nicu, right?
- Yeah, yeah it is.
- Yucky Nicu is really good.
- It is.
- They are both amazing,
but it's like it's definitely
a different vibe, I feel.
- Do you have any favorite Korean dishes
or just any favorite food in general?
- I mean I'm a sucker for just
a good piping (indistinct)
- Oh God.
- Yes.
- In like the proper Korean
one, like the stone bowl.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's still crackling as it comes out.
- Yeah.
It's just really good and
it's nice and spicy and warm
and it's good winter food,
but there's also another one called,
I think it's seolleongtang,
which is like an ox-bone broth.
- Yeah, I've had that once and it's-
- It's very tasty.
- It's tasty and it just cleans the soul.
That's what it feels like.
I remember one time, I was
like one of the most hungover
I've ever been in Korea.
- Yeah.
- I felt awful
and had like the ox-bone soup
and it just felt like
my body was just like
so refreshed afterwards.
- Yeah.
- I don't know what you guys put in there,
but like it's like the ancient herbal,
like the ancient herbal medicine
that everyone talks about,
that's what it felt like.
- Used for a thousand.
- Right.
- Mix it in.
- Yeah.
I'm a big fan of like a Mandu chicken,
which is like a dumpling stew as well.
- Okay, okay.
- It's stuff that I
wouldn't get here really.
And it was like, yeah, it's so good.
- There's probably a lot of stuff
that you can't really get here, right?
- Yeah.
- At least not proper.
- Yeah. I still stand by the Korean food
is my favorite food in the world.
- I love Korean fried chicken.
- I love it.
- It's amazing.
- Korean fried chicken is
also fucken incredible.
- I don't realize that Koreans
have perfected fried chicken.
- It's the best, they have the best.
- I think Koreans have the best
fried chicken in the world.
- To be fair, I don't
think I've ever heard
or met anyone who has said
that they don't like Korean food, so-
- Yeah.
It's pretty difficult.
- The British haven't
had it, that's a lot-
- Well, they haven't had the good one.
- Yeah, because I guess like
Korean food wasn't as popular,
I guess like 10 years ago or something.
'Cause I remember like I'd
never even tried Korean food
until around like 10 years ago.
And then 'cause it was all like, you know,
you see like Indian food
or like Japanese food
or Chinese food and like
I'd never got a chance
to try Korean cuisine.
And then remember the
first time trying it.
I was like, why is this
not more, more popular?
You know, why is this not more widespread?
- Yeah.
K-Pop are doing a lot of the
heavy lifting on that one.
- Yes, yes, yes, yes.
- Yeah, spreading into
the world, which is great.
'Cause now we have like a good
Korean restaurant in Brighton
called Cogi, which is just meat.
But it does like legit Korean food.
- Cool.
- It's so good.
- Gotta check it out, I think that's new.
- Is it new since, or has
it been around for a while?
- I think it was right before pandemic
and I'm so happy that
pandemic didn't kill it.
- Okay.
- Because I was very worried.
I was like, you haven't
been open long enough
to like have a float of cash.
- Yeah, right.
- It's like survive this,
but I think there's still going strong.
- Yeah, 'cause I feel like in Brighton now
there's just like,
like there's been a lot of
restaurants been popping up now
because I obviously moved out Brighton
just before the pandemic and even then,
I wasn't really living
in Brighton as well.
I was more living in Thailand.
So just seeing like, one thing
that I've learned from Japan
is I love food culture.
I love restaurant culture
and I come back to Brighton
and now there's like every
cuisine under the sun,
there's like cool restaurants.
And I'm like fuck, yes.
- Yeah.
So like another thing I guess
that you've been doing a lot recently
is the whole touring thing, right?
- Yeah.
- And as someone who, well,
as we are about to do our very first tour,
like I wanna know as like,
the upperclassmen like, oh,
you know the experienced one of tours,
like is there-
- The sampler
- Yeah, the sampler of
tours, is there like any,
I guess like, how different
is it to like say, you know,
a regular convention or
like really like anything?
- It's so much better
than regular content.
It's like, 'cause like,
well this is great 'cause
you actually have people
to talk to, to laugh and joke around with.
But when you're on your own
and you're recording a let's
play and it's like, am I funny?
- Nope.
And then you're just waiting
for the cameras to laugh back.
And it doesn't, it's
like when I went on tour,
I came back and I was
miserable 'cause I was like,
I don't know how to make videos anymore.
It's so uncomfortable.
And just by myself and
nothing I'm saying is funny.
And I think some of that
still lingers around today,
but it's such a fun, electric energy.
And I was doing them like every
day and going out to a show
and seeing so many parts
of the world and again,
food culture is such a massive part.
- Hell, yeah.
- The best part of tour is
everything between your show.
'Cause I had a really good tour family
and everyone was very mature
and there was no like egos anywhere
and everyone was just so nice
and I got to know them so well.
- Well man, the fact that
you call it a family,
and not a team just says a lot,
like they say a tour team, they say team,
this is the family, guys.
- We're family.
- Vin Diesel.
We 'cause you just spend,
everyone's like sleeping on
the bus and you all kinda like
you're in such close
proximity to each other.
- Right.
- But if any ego is there,
you'll know it immediately.
And everyone will get
on each other's nerves,
but we just have so much fun
going to restaurants and like,
oh this is the biggest
restaurant in this city,
let's go there.
- And yeah, we would hang out
and just drink after the shows
or go to a place like a day early,
we went to Florida and I
got to see like Universal
and got to go to the
Harry Potter land there.
- Awesome. Awesome.
- Just like most of my best
memories are probably from tour.
- What's like the wildest location
that you remember from
like any of your tours
where it's like, I wanna
go back and do a show there
or like I wanna go back
there to like experience,
you know what I experienced
during pre or post show?
- Yeah, the weirdest one
I think was New Orleans,
which sorry, New Orleans.
(laughing)
Which wasn't selling well initially.
And then they were like,
oh they're a musical town.
Like they'll show up on the day
and they'll buy tickets at the door.
And then I got there and they didn't.
So half the theater was empty.
It was like daylight out,
I could see everybody.
And it was like, people
were yelling at each other
in the crowd at each other.
- During the show?
- Yeah.
- Being like you're great.
Somebody else being like, "Shut
the up, he's doing a show."
Be like, no, you shut the up.
And I was like, I'm probably
remembering it far more
like hyperbolic than it was.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That was like New Orleans
is such a weird town
'cause if a place called
the French quarter, I think,
and that was like all
the old time buildings
and like what you think New
Orleans looks like and right.
That area of the world.
And it was like right after Mardi GRA.
- Right.
- So there were many people
out like still celebrating that.
And then it was just like,
it was almost like a line in
the sand and then suddenly,
it's just metropolis out of nowhere.
So it was like going from
old to new immediately
and all these people out in
the streets, all having fun.
And there was like a death museum there
and we had like crawfish
and then I had snails
for the first time there.
And it was all these like
experiences back to back
where I was like, right.
I am not wait, pause.
- What the hell is a death museum?
- Where you go and like,
look at stuff and find like
dead bodies and pieces of like.
- That's just a cemetery?
(laughing)
- No, you get to see them.
It's like a cemetery with windows.
- At the end, you join the museum.
- Yeah.
- It's just like a lot
of stuff about like the
history of like death
and like medical culture
and how they discover stuff.
- Cool.
- Pretty sure the history
of death goes all the way
to the star of humanity, you know.
- Have you go all the way to the end.
- You know, this guy, Isaac
Death discovered death
and humanity just was
never the same again.
- Yeah.
He brought it upon everybody,
but that was a weird experience.
So it was just a lot of
like crazy shit happening.
- But then I think the coolest
one was probably Florida.
'Cause I got to do it in Universal.
So it's like-
- oh wow.
It was like the Hard
Rock Cafe in Universal.
So I kept hearing like we're
doing the Hard Rock Cafe
and I was like, those are a big deal.
And then we were like
walking around universal
and I was like, is the hard
rock I'm doing bigger than this?
They were like, that is
the one you're doing.
- Oh wow.
- So we actually had to
like go into like the start
of Universal to see it.
- Wow.
- And there were
so many people outside of it.
And I think there was something about it
like it was the first one
or it was the biggest one
in the world, like the hard rock.
- Right.
- And then we got
a private tour around it and got to see
the upper area where like
Paul McCartney stuff was and-.
- Oh my God.
- Awesome.
- Elvis's stuff was like lying around.
I was like, okay, that's pretty cool.
- That sounds awesome.
- That's authentic stuff.
- Yeah, and then doing it
and like the floor design
of that one was like
a perfect semi-circle.
And I was able to talk
to everyone perfectly.
The acoustics were great.
The show slapped harder
than it did in most places.
- Ah, awesome.
- What did you do in the shows?
- I did a mix of like
stand-up with small snippets
of gameplay in it, so right.
It was like a story about my life done
in a standup comedy way
where I would tell stories
of my past with like punch
lines and everything.
- Okay, right.
- But then it was broken up
into three acts where I
would have like act one
would be like my childhood
and here's where I grew up
and everything about that.
And then I played a moted Pokemon blue.
'Cause that was the first
game I remember getting
that I loved.
- Right, right.
But the game, the characters in it,
like we set it up that
you fought your rival,
you had to fight six Pokemon,
but all six were named after
hard things in your life,
like fear, death.
- Oh, cool.
- And then the last one
was called rent.
(laughing)
- So we'd bring someone
up on stage to play it
and then give them a chance to like,
be a YouTuber for like 20 minutes.
- And then we'd move on
to like my teenage years.
And that was like, when
I was like depressed
and lived in a cabin in the woods
and was miserable and kinda like just sort
of like relate to the audience.
And then the last one
was we played "Shadow
of the Colossus" for that one.
'Cause I discovered that
game during that period.
And then someone came up and played that
and then adulthood was all about YouTube
and where I went from there
and how I uplifted myself out of that.
And then we played "Happy
Wheels" on stage because-
- It scores.
- It was the most hype game
to play life ever.
- Yeah, right.
- But the whole point of the show
was to kinda like relate the story
of my life entertaining
wise, but to show them like,
here's where I came
from, here's what I did.
Nothing is special, I'm nobody.
Here I am like doing it.
- Yeah.
- How do you make sure
a show doesn't suck?
- I don't know.
- Fuck!
- 'Cause we were hoping you'd tell us
so that our show doesn't end up sucking.
- Do you write the show,
and then you're like, it's not funny?
How do I make this funny?
- Do you call up
the screenwriters in L.A.?
Help me out, bro.
- Call up Uber drivers in another.
- I did it with real go touring
was like Brent and Aaron
and those guys.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, we're doing it as well.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- So I like wrote out
the structure of it and they were like,
so can you perform it for us?
And I did practice shows to
like 400 people in like Chicago
and stuff and I did it
and I was like, okay,
it's a show finally, whew.
Like I never wrote out the jokes properly.
I kind of just improv.
I had like pillars to
hint, kinda like improv.
As I went there.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- And then as the show progressed,
I got better and better at it
and like trimmed the fat a little.
- And yeah.
- But it it'll work 'cause you
guys know each other so well
and you've been around
each other so long and you,
you bounce like the same
humor off each other, so-
- Right.
- Hopefully.
- You're right.
- How much like how much
planning went into like,
I guess don't like the actual
like planning the logistics,
but like the content of the
tour or the shows itself?
- The narrative, like
how long did that take?
- How long did that take to come out?
- I think for me it was like four months.
- Wow.
- But I kind of knew
what I wanted going into it.
Like I had the idea to
do 'cause Bob Burnham
had released "Make Happy" at the time.
- Right.
- Special before insight.
- And I was like,
I wanna do something like
that where it's like,
I always wanted to try stand up anyway.
I didn't wanna get up
and do what I always do,
but kind of a little bit to
like pander to the audience
with the games and stuff.
- Right.
- But I wanted it to make sense in it.
But the whole point was that
I wanted to do something fun,
but have like a message at the end of it.
- Right, right, right.
- And the final line of the show was like,
go out and be the heroes of your own story
and like empower people
to like do the thing.
'Cause everyone looks at
this stuff and they're like,
how did you do it?
Who do you know?
They like got you here.
And like Pew Die Pie, shout
out and all this stuff.
They think that like these
specific steps need to happen.
I grew up in a town of 600 people
and knew nothing about the world.
And I fucked up tons
of times along the way.
And I was miserable and
depressed and hated myself
and failed college and I still got up
and talked to people on a stage.
- Yeah.
- Like anybody can do it, really.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You make it sound a lot easier.
- If it's not good, that's the difference.
- It's a different type of show.
You don't have to get up
and have that specific-
- True.
- I mean, you sound like it was,
it sounds like an amazing show
with an amazing amount of preparation
and content that's gone into it.
- As long as you know you wanted to do.
- Yeah, yeah.
And I'm saying listening,
I'm sitting here
listening, being like guys.
So he set the standard, but don't-
- Don't expect to our show
to be like that, please.
- We're not in "Free Guy".
- Yeah, the tour did a lot for me and-
- Well, my Ryan Reynolds
is in the audience.
- I feel like I'm just a good bullshitter.
I feel like I can get
up and like talk off.
- Isn't that YouTuber, got every YouTuber.
- I feel like I can like talk
myself out of any scenario.
So I feel like,
I really enjoy live stuff
and I enjoy a lot more than
like scripted stuff doesn't
really play that well with me.
- Do you enjoy live streaming much?
- No.
- That's so odd.
So you enjoy live stuff
but not live streaming?
- 'Cause I can't hear them.
- Ah, by live, you mean like
the feedback of like emotions.
- And it's like you're in the space
and everyone's there
for a specific energy.
And if like we had a thing
at the start, I was like,
put away your phones. You've
seen me throw a screen enough.
Like now's not the time to do that.
- Is that what's gonna happen
to Connor after our talk?
He said he's gonna try and
go back in the livestream
and be like, it's not the same.
- When I don't hear the
pogs in like the crowd.
- Where's the off track dude?
- Maybe, maybe, maybe I'll go live.
And I'm like, this is boring.
Where's the feed?
I wanna see.
- Just have a fucken sound deck
where you just play a
laugh every now and then.
- Did you?
- It is more fun to do it live.
And I feel like because
the show wouldn't translate
to a video well.
We did the documentary
and everything of it,
but we still pulled out so
much of the show from it.
'Cause I'm like none of these jokes land
if you're not there.
- Of course, right, right.
- And everyone's there to giggle
and everyone's there to
like anything you say
will make them laugh.
And I feel like nothing's
like taken outta context.
Nothing is weird about it.
No one like takes something
and then brings it somewhere else.
- Yeah.
- And I feel like live
streaming is a lot of that
where I could say something
and you could take it outta context
and put it somewhere else.
And seeing people show up,
I'm such a people pleaser.
So if somebody says I hate this
and it's one out of like a
thousand, I'll still see it.
And it'd like ruined my whole mood.
- [All] Oh!
- So I empathize with
people way too easily.
And if someone's not having
a good time, I'm like,
it's my fault, I fucked it up.
I'm like, why am I live?
Why did I go live if people
aren't enjoying themselves?
- Did you get many hecklers
or anything like that
you had to deal with live?
- Not like bad hecklers, okay.
- All right.
- Just people
who are enthusiastic,
who treated it like a
panel at a convention.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- And I like lost my trail of thought
and I fucked up one of the jokes one night
and said like the punchline way too early.
- How do you recover from
that on stage, though?
- Yeah, I didn't, I just moved on.
- It was awful.
I like froze.
And I had maybe if you do your live show,
you'll have this experience.
'cause other people I've
talked to have had it
where you go on.
I had done the show like,
like 30 times at this point.
And then at some point I
was like saying the show
and I like drifted out of my body.
And I was like, what if
I fuck this up right now?
And I was like, I could say anything.
I could say the most horrific ever
that would ruin everything.
And then I was like, wait,
I'm not even paying
attention to what I'm saying.
And my mouth was just like
saying all of the jokes.
- Right.
- And I was like,
I came back into my body and I was like,
I've never had that experience before.
- Wow.
- And some therapist is like,
"Yeah, you have a condition."
- Yeah, come see me in my office.
- Yeah, well that was so bizarre
how your brain just like takes
over and just works through.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I guess you'd probably
get doing live streams.
- Yeah, I guess so.
- Like thinking about dinner
and everyone's in chat,
like you're just making jokes still.
- Yeah, you can definitely
autopilot it after a while.
- I mean, sometimes I do
on this podcast, you know,
not even with live audience,
sometimes I'm just like,
my mouth is like moving right now,
but I dunno what point I'm trying to make.
- I'm just saying shit but
in the back of my mind,
I'm like, God, I gotta take a shit.
- Do you have ADHD by any chance?
- Yes, I do, yes.
- But I actually only got
recently diagnosed actually.
- Me, too, like two months ago.
- Hell yeah, high five.
(hands clap)
ADHD player.
- Wish I could join in this flex.
- I can't, either.
I'm just fascinated to
know how many people
who do this job have ADHD,
'cause I'm convinced it's like 80%.
- I think it's a lot.
- Yeah.
- Every live streamer I know has ADHD.
I think it's impossible to
be a successful streamer
if you don't.
- I dunno about that.
- To be honest, like it's
because it's, you know,
'cause it's so much stimuli, right?
- It is.
- Yeah.
- And there's so much multitasking.
And I guess even like at the beginning,
it just felt so overwhelming. Right?
Like you have like you,
you want to play the game,
you want to do whatever activity,
but then you have to have like a second,
like a third eye to
keep an eye on the chat
and everything like that.
It's like, it's just do it.
- And then it becomes second nature.
But like I remember when you start-
When you start off, it's like-
- Oh, it's too much.
- Yeah.
I've said these guys, but I enjoy,
I don't really enjoy gaming
if I'm not doing it on stream.
I feel like, unless I see those
like funny little emotes popping
up in the corner of my eye,
I'm like some of my brain-
- There's a hall for content.
- I think maybe I am.
I think I am a hall for content.
I think-
- I mean, there's nothing wrong with it.
- Yeah, if I don't need that cake,
it doesn't get me up in the morning, man.
- Something about seeing
that Spanish guy laughing,
you know, that just
makes me feel so happy.
I'm like, I made a joke and people laugh,
even though it wasn't funny, but yeah.
God, these paid act actors are great.
(laughing)
- What you have is called a parasocial.
- Maybe I'm parasocial.
I'm like, guys, please turn up.
- People laugh at my joke.
- Yeah.
- It's like usually something
to like making your own schedule
I think ADHD people relate to.
- Yeah, definitely.
Because like, that's why to me,
I could never be like a
full-time streamer, I think,
because you know, with a streams,
sometimes you always feel the pressure
to be streamed like certain
hours, you know, at least
like real professional streamers,
where with YouTube-
- Professional stream.
- Yeah.
Well, but like with YouTube,
my like my like productivity
is not like a linear curve.
So I'll have like certain days,
certain weeks where I'm just like on it
and then certain months where
just like nothing happens
and I dunno what to do about it.
And it just like, it goes up and down.
So that's one big
difference between I think,
YouTube and Twitch streaming that I enjoy.
- I mean, you upload
it every day with ADHD.
- I basically had a stream
of schedule on YouTube.
- Yeah.
I mean, I have done the
streaming thing for a while.
We did the roast server like years ago.
- Oh right, right.
- With all the among us crew.
And I was streaming like
eight hours some days
and like staying up till
6:00 a.m. to play it.
But after that, I dunno, it
just made me anxious to go live.
I feel like I can make
something more entertaining
when it's paced around editing.
- Right.
- But if it's me, I
just find myself boring.
- You think that's like too much downtime
between the highlights, I guess.
- Yeah, I dunno.
Maybe that's just like a background kind
of brain thing going on.
- Right, right, right.
- I dunno if the, just the
feeling of having to like,
please people live just kind of got to me.
- Yeah.
I can imagine like, 'cause
I guess like I can relate
because when you feel like you do have
to like always be on it and
always like be entertaining,
it's just so draining, you know?
Whereas, you know, with, I
guess like with the let's play,
you can take a break
and you just like, okay,
this part's gonna be
edited out, no pressure.
But when it's live,
you constantly feel like
you have eyes watching you.
- Yeah, plus if I stream, like you said,
there's a certain amount of hours.
Like if you stream less than two hours,
everyone's like go away.
but it just got in the way of other work.
Like there's other things I want to do.
Like my YouTube would suffer for it.
And if I'm not uploading those streams,
then what's the point?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'm a much better YouTuber
than I am a streamer.
- Right, right, right.
- It's not the same skillset at all.
- Yeah, definitely.
- Despite what people think.
- No, no, definitely not.
Going back to the tool,
I'm wondering like,
did you find that there was
like different crowd energy
in like the different places that you went
and you had to like kind
of tailor your performance
to wherever you were
or like the energy that you felt?
- Yeah, I mean, that's what I was saying,
how you can tell Americans
are just far more boisterous about things.
For a life scenario, that's fucken amazing
'cause they will cheer
you on to everything.
- And they're so they're
so much like more energetic
and they're just so much more,
maybe they're more attuned
to live culture or something,
I don't know.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Or maybe you're just
loud, but it's great.
Made me feel awesome.
But then going to Europe,
it was very different
'cause there's like some
jokes that are kind of like,
like about Ireland and
like being a Catholic boy
and being an altar boy in
church and things like that.
And I think Americans relate
to Irish people very much,
considering they all
tell me they're Irish.
- Yeah.
- But don't know
any places from there.
- But I think business factory,
of course you go to Boston
and suddenly everyone's Irish.
- Yeah.
- But places like France and Germany,
like there was language barriers and stuff
and like Irish humor didn't
really play as easily.
People were still fun and they had energy
and they were still energetic about it.
But some places laugh more than others.
And then having a joke about like,
I had a joke about being an altar boy.
And then I was saying like teenage years
got dark or whatever.
And it was like a joke
about basically hinting
at like priest versus altar boy culture.
- Right, right.
- But not saying
anything about it,
obviously just letting
the audience make that interpretation.
And then I was like, no,
not that kind of show.
And people would laugh, but
Salt Lake City did not like-
(laughing)
- Wrong crowd.
- It's like Mormon Mecca.
- Right, right, right.
- Where all the Mormons like go
and like big churches right there.
And they were kind of
like, they were like,
don't like that one.
- Do people like come up to you
after the show, for example,
And be like, "Oh hey, I
really liked your show.
But like this joke was kind weird."
'Cause you hear about
like comedians doing that.
- Right.
- Like after the show,
they'd like go into the crowd
and be like meet the fans
or like...
- It turns out it's really easy
when you're not transphobic.
(laughing)
- If you're not saying racist
shit, transphobic shit,
homophobic shit, it's
real easy to put on a show
without any jokes in there.
- What a hot take.
- Only the hottest stakes
here in "Trash Taste".
- It's really easy not to punch down on.
- That's true.
- Oh yeah, wow.
- But I mean my jokes
never really went that far,
and a lot of stuff is about my life
and my experience through it.
So it's like, luckily.
- You weren't a transphobic racist.
- Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Life's much better on your not, though.
- When a joke doesn't
land, does it like...
'Cause I can imagine it like
in like a Twitch scenario.
I can't imagine it in a life scenario
where you're just like this
joke's gonna land, it's-
- Because if you say a
joke on Twitch, right,
the worst thing you'll have is someone
in the chat like that wasn't funny.
- Yeah, sure.
- But it went they're in
front of you doing that,
I'm sure it hurts a lot more, right?
- Yeah, there's been a couple of times
where like I have a big punchline.
And there was like one joke
near the end of the show
that even now, like,
I just didn't know how to
get the punchline across.
- Right.
- And I would say it and then
people laughed at the thing
before a little louder.
Oh, that's not the punchline.
Like do I move on from this
now, like cut off there
but I'm a hall for a for a laugh.
I'll keep hammering it
until someone laughs.
And then if it's really cringey,
you just lean into that and
be like, huh, no takers.
oh, okay.
I thought we were here for a comedy show,
but I guess not.
And then the show in London,
I did it at the Trocksy Theater and it,
I dunno why I said that.
No one fucken knows where that is,
but I did it there and
the projector broke.
So the hasty, my connection didn't work.
So when I had to have the game
on screen, it didn't show up.
So I had to like vamp for a
bit and like build up the crowd
and like bake it into the show.
People said it was funny, and I'm like,
you got a more unique
experience I guess, out of it.
So sometimes the cringe kinda like helps,
but there's definitely times
where I'm like drowning
on stage and I'm like,
please just now, I don't
have enough material.
- That makes me feel good
that at least I have these two to rely on.
(laughing)
- Yeah, I don't think I could ever do
like a solo like stage show.
- If we drown, we drown together.
- With enough prep,
you'd be able to do it.
- Right.
- I think any of you would be able to
- I hope so.
- You're too kind.
- But for this time around, at
least it'll just be us three.
We got each other's back, Yeah.
- What, what are you guys
gonna do in the show?
- That's a really good question.
- Well, I mean like I
start thinking about that.
- I mean, without
spoiling any of the ideas
that we have right now,
like the general idea is to bring
the "Trash Taste" experience,
which we are famous for just on stage.
- Like basically what you are
experiencing right now, Sean,
we wanna give the audience
a little bit of a taste
of basically, you know, being on the show,
being part of the show kind of right.
- Have pace, hopefully.
- But hopefully being a pace on a lot
with less tangents maybe.
- Yeah. Yeah.
We'll see how it goes.
It'll be more structured
than one of our episodes,
but it'll be like, you know,
the highlights of why you
like the "Trash Taste" show
and everything just brought on stage.
- Sure, you'll have your own running jokes
that you can bring back.
- Do we have our own running-
- Many, yeah. (laughing)
- I mean bring people up on stage.
That's always a crowd pleaser as well.
- And that's always so scary though.
Like what if you accidentally bring
the wrong kind of person up on stage.
- Oh yeah, that-
- I'm sure that's happened.
- Yeah.
- It happened in Iowa
where it's like, I brought
people up and being like,
do you have a YouTube
name 'cause it's like,
if you're gonna sit in the
chair and like do the thing.
If you have a YouTube now
is the time to shout it out
so many people here will
go home and watch you,
if you're good at this. But
then it was a chance for people
to make up their own name.
Then I would make up like Teddy Sprinkles
and things like that.
But then one guy got up and said
that he was our Wood Giraffe.
And I was like, and the crowd cheered.
And I was like, okay,
I was like, nah, you've
got a different name.
And I kinda just had to like cut it off
and like move on immediately.
But you don't wanna
like warm the crowd out
and like admonish the person on stage.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
- But at the same time, it's
kind of weird to be like,
all right, thank you all Wood Giraffe.
Welcome, on stage.
It was just-
- Round of applause.
- Round of applause for Wood Giraffe.
- It was tough.
- Yeah.
- Oh my God.
- Yeah, I guess that just
comes with the experience then
that like hearing your
stories that scares me,
but it also makes me excited.
It sounds like a very,
very fun experience.
- I mean, I think everyone there kind of,
'cause you're not like
professional comedians.
You're not like John
Mulaney getting up, so.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- People expect them
to handle it better,
unlike hecklers and stuff.
'cause they've been doing it for years
and there's like a formula to it.
But I think with our type of content,
I think people are far more forgiving
if you kinda like stall on
stage and people are like,
I wouldn't know how to deal with that.
- Yeah.
But like I also think
like a lot of YouTubers,
we started off doing YouTube videos
because we were not good
at maybe like speaking
in front of like a public audience
or maybe that's just how we were as a kid.
We never thought that we'd
be like standing up on stage
in a panel and public speaking basically.
- Yeah.
- And so it's just, it's been,
sometimes it's a real learning
curve to be like, maybe this,
this is actually really fun.
And it's a skill that you
develop in your career,
which you never thought
you would, I guess.
- Yeah. I think the secret
to me for live shows
was to not be afraid of the audience.
Because there's a tendency that
there's so many more of them
and now they're here and
they demand a good show
'cause they're paying for it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But if they started
heckling or anything,
I would just like shit
on them immediately.
- Right.
- It's not a fucken classroom.
Like you don't have all the
answers and like bake that into
the show and then they're kinda
like, okay, I'll be quiet.
- Right, right, right.
(laughing)
- Or if someone gets up
and says the wrong thing,
then you just hand them the mic
and be like, okay, good luck.
Like you handle the crowd.
There's a bunch of
little things like that.
And I think getting over that
fear of like the audience
can't like destroy me while I'm up here.
- Should, should have taken notes.
- Yeah, right.
- If only there was some
other way you could look back.
- Yeah, yeah, you know.
- I can't watch back.
- I don't watch my own shows.
I guess like one thing
I wanna ask is someone
who has been doing it for
this long and who has amassed,
you know, the amount of subscribers-
- The cult, yeah.
- The cult essentially.
It's like, how do you see,
I guess the future of like
content creation on YouTube?
Because it's like, you
know, you've obviously hit
a point that a lot of
people today have not hit.
'Cause like I could never relate.
Obviously, it's like where you are.
So it's like, I wanna know,
do you reckon, as
someone in your position,
do you see like a future for
YouTube content creation?
Because like you were mentioning
how like recent, you know,
culture around YouTube.
You're not a massive fan of.
- Not really.
I don't blame it and I
don't like hate anybody
who like plays into it.
But for me, it's not
why I started my stuff.
And it's all like idea,
title and thumbnail first
before anything else anymore.
And then yes it is.
And people have like, oh I have an idea.
How do I do this in like Fortnite?
'Cause it's like, well
I have to get Fortnite
in there as well.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's like people
are just playing the game and that's fine,
but I've never liked doing that.
I'm always like if I
find a game that's like
a random Japanese horror game
that suddenly gets 4 million views
and then it's like, that feels better.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And I seeing that
in the trending tab feels
better than seeing all the same.
- Like you don't wanna be like
a slave to the SEO basically.
- Kind of, yeah.
I feel like my channel's
been as successful as it is,
like I have the privilege of being able
to do whatever I want.
- You played "The Closing Shift".
I'd played that recently as well.
And that was an experience.
- That was phenomenal.
- What a Starbucks
simulator with horror in it.
It's a played it.
- But I saw a lot of YouTubers playing.
- It's so good. I didn't
know what to expect.
And it's just the right amount of junk
to have so much character.
- Well, right.
- [Connor] God, the game is-
- Yeah, 'cause I started going back
and playing much more
of their other games.
And that "Closing Shift" one
is definitely their best one.
Like they've started to like hone in
on what they're good at.
- Basically you work at a Starbucks
and anyone doesn't know and
you have a stalker and yeah.
That's kind of it that's okay.
- I saw a bunch of clips,
it looks genuinely unknown.
- Not the worst jump scan
in video game history.
That fucken woman with the pram.
- Yeah, with no baby in it.
- I lost my fucken heart.
- Crazy to drop kick a child.
- But it's just like
tip the pram over you.
- But it's also kinda scary
'cause you play as a woman
like at night in this place
with all these dudes like hitting on you
and it's like, right.
This happens.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's not even like
a ghost showing up.
It's like just weirdo.
- Yeah, I think it's
just the it's got that.
I love this game.
It was amazing, it was so much fun.
Please play it if you haven't,
because it'll have this super seriousness
and it really builds up this tension
and then a guy will come in
and start beat like naked break dancing.
- Yeah.
- Oh yeah, saw that clear.
- This game that just in
the best way cannot decide
what theme or who it wants to give you.
And then it like disarms you though.
'Cause you're scared.
And then this guy comes
in, you're laughing.
And then you're like,
oh I really close up.
And then a you get jumped.
Ah it's so good.
- And then the other dude comes in.
He is like, no need to
ni hungo joze mi me.
- So good.
- And I'm like fuck off.
- Is that a natural line?
- Honestly, it's such a good game.
Yeah.
And 90% of it is you making
coffees and it's so stressful.
- Yeah, definitely gonna try that out.
- It's so good.
I think especially as a content creator,
that's definitely that aspect of like
this stalking thing is a little too loud,
a little too close.
- Yeah, It's just made
by two Japanese brothers.
They just go by Chillers Art online.
But they make really, really good games.
'Cause their old stuff is
all like supernatural shit.
I feel like they're really
getting into like real stuff.
- Yeah.
- And it's so much scarier.
- Now that you like your
content is so like obviously
like revolved around gaming before.
Has that changed your
relationship with gaming at all?
- No, I game all the fucken time.
- Are you a gamer?
Are you a gamer?
- And I have a girlfriend.
(laughing)
Impossible.
He's also touch grass.
- I mean I still pick and
choose what I play more,
I think this time.
And still sometimes I'm
like a game comes out.
I'm like, fuck I should have
played that on my channel.
It was so good.
- Right, right, right.
- It's like very hit and miss sometimes.
And then I dunno, I just, I
like having games for myself.
I think that's my favorite pastime still.
And I like how they're made
and I always kind of wanted
to get into game design
and voice work and stuff.
So I think from a mechanical standpoint.
Still really like them
quite a bit and artistically
and they're just so good. And
they just keep getting better
with so many to play.
- What's like your recent favorite game?
- "Elden Ring".
- Yeah, I was gonna say that,
I knew he's got "Elden Ring".
- It's all good.
- Surprise, surprise.
- They won't play it, I don't know why.
- No, don't put words in my mouth.
- Let's play it right now.
- No, no.
- The thing is I know I'm gonna like it.
That's exactly why I'm haven't started yet
because you love ""Berserk""
and haven't played...
Have you played the other ones?
- Yes, I have.
- Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
I've played "Blood" more than
like the "Dark Soul" games.
I love FromSoft,
but like I know I'll get into
it and that's exactly why I'm
scared to get into it.
It's like "Final Fantasy XIV"
Like I know I'll get into it,
but I know if I start,
commitments out the window.
- It's worth it.
- It definitely ruined
my life for a long.
- Was worth it, it's like amazing.
- Yeah, it is.
Well, like if it had come out
like this time, last year,
like in the middle of the pandemic-
- It was supposed to
come out earlier, okay.
No need to rub it in.
- Right?
- We waited so long.
- Exactly.
- It was the perfect pandemic game.
And now I'm like traveling
in like fucken four different countries
in like three months or whatever.
I'm like, this is, it'll be there.
- Yeah.
It is definitely a
daunting task to take on,
'cause the first place
there was like 70 hours.
- Yeah.
- Then meanwhile, there's
a guy who can beat him
like three minutes.
- Well, he's been playing
"Elden Ring", right
- Yeah, yeah.
- He's playing "Dance Dance Revolution",
and shit is happening on the screens.
- He's like coding the game.
- Yeah, yeah.
- The zapping speed runs
are like, what the is the point to this?
- I mean, he doesn't even
like them on his dreams.
He's like, I wish I could fight things.
- Right.
(laughing)
- I wish I could play the game.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- His blood born one
is still really, really good.
And that's all like
perfecting like the craft,
affecting the bosses.
- Yeah.
- I think that-
I guess like final question,
like is that you've done
already so much of your career.
Is there anything left you
want to do in the future?
- I don't know.
- Like you've done multiple tours,
now you've a master massive following.
You've met Ryan Reynolds.
Like I don't think there's
anything else where-
- Where does it go from Ryan Reynolds?
- How do you top Ryan Reynolds?
- I dunno.
(laughing)
- Co-starring with Ryan.
- Yeah.
- I think narrative stuff
is kind of where I'm headed.
I kind had like projects in
the back of my head and stuff
that I've wanted to do for a long time,
like stories and right.
Like acting out characters and stuff.
And I think I'll probably get into that.
- Write a book?
- Hell no.
(laughing) There was a big
pressure to write books years ago
when everyone was doing them.
And I was like, I haven't lived a life.
Like what am I gonna write about?
- I think you have now.
- Yeah, the Jack cookbook.
- You can write a whole chapter
on just being friends.
- The World Cup DVD.
- With Ryan Reynolds.
- What is the World Cup DVD?
- Yeah, I don't know.
I just kinda wanna focus
on the coffee stuff
and I feel like I haven't even
like nearly started cranking
that as much as I could.
- Right, right.
- Just kinda before it was like taking
on too many things and doing
them all kind of poorly.
- Right.
- Now I'm kind of taking
a few things and doing them a
bit better and focus and yeah.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, sounds like it.
- Good mindset.
- Sounds like a good path.
Well I guess.
- Well thank you for
coming on the show today.
- No problem, thank you for having me.
- Some these paetrons though.
- Oh my God.
- You see all them, Jack?
Look at them all.
They're flying Out everywhere.
- Why are they here?
- Because they support the show.
- People pay for this?
(laughing)
- Isn't that crazy?
- That name there, you paid for it.
This is just a shame credit.
- Hey, if you'd like to
join the shame credits,
go over to our page
Patreon.com/TrashTaste.
Also follow on Twitter, send
us to memes on the sub-reader.
And if you had our face, listen
to us on Spotify and yeah.
I mean you already know
who fucken Jack is.
- Do you wanna shout out?
- You know who it is.
- Do you wanna shout
out your socials, Jack?
- My coffee?
- Oh yeah, there you.
- Oh yeah.
- My socials mean nothing.
- What is the topofthemorningcoffee.com.
- Well, there you, we go, there you go.
- Did I get that right?
- Yeah.
- Oh, hell yeah.
- Your sponsors for this
episode are gonna be very upset.
- No, it's fine, it's fine.
- I want another one.
- Yeah, thanks for coming on, man.
- Thank you.
- Very fun.
- Thank you very much.
- And we'll see you guys in
the next episode as well.
- [All] Bye.
- Stay weeby.
(laughing)
(vibrant music)